peu
[Musique]
la tour nom de quoi tu me parles tu
rigoles ou quoi la radio à la télé les
journaux tout le monde enfin à l'autre
et oui ce matin je suis allé au pressing
m'attends à tout on parlait aussi bios
et enfin oui lui aussi fils en bas ça
veut dire que tout le monde amis du
samedi soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle
l'émission pas comme les autres vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle alors tout le monde en parle
ils connaissent et l'équipe aussi longue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sachet de là
non
lui
mise à part laurent baffie je recevrai
ce soir
mathilde seigner nourrissent néerlandais
ce modèle
arrêt juin
je me ménage
s'il tonne
christine ockrent
et michel desjoyeaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
elle pour animer arbitré le blind test
massue à philippe corti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous aviez une tradition dans cette
émission c'est les meilleurs moments de
la semaine précédente sont rediffusés
chaque semaine c'est le best-of de la
semaine s'est préparée par jean noël et
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
mais nous avons saisi tla est prête à
les caresser ou vous faire caresser ou
ça est-ce que vous avez un fantasme non
encore assouvi carrément avec des pommes
de terre j'ai pas tellement de fantasmes
y'a pas un truc vous dit comme ça
j'aimerais bien le faire j'aime bien moi
c'est les chiens sur la bouche au jeu de
patates dans les maps
on a été très discret n'a pas fait
le groupe
bon tu as une bonne guillon d'un côté on
est toutes tes blagues gueule et ses
patates
est ce que j'y arriverai mois dans les
coups de poing un jour j'étais arrivé
avec la gueule complètement déformés je
m'étais fait déchirer la tronche dans
une bagarre et où je t'avais dit que je
m'étais fait choper dans métro avec ma
femme justement en fait j'étais allé
dans une soirée les potes et ça va
terminer en baston générale les mecs
avaient dit du mal de moi et tu m'avais
défendu bcsa voilà est-ce que tu aime
toujours les nuits blanches
oui mais maintenant quand j'ai des
blanches c'est pour travailler c'est
plus pour sortir ce que tu te fout de
notre gueule
dernier coup de rein là sa femme parce
que c'est un mois et demi que je suis
donc en tournée que balkanique frédéric
me rejoint demain oh [ __ ] quand ça que
j'ai la banane aulas
les costauds sont champions du monde de
hand ball je peux permettre gendre et
handball tu dis quoi
un bol il faut dire football et handball
voilà oui oui oui oui ça n'est pas mes
origines et le truc bold est ce que vous
détestez dans le sexe qu'ils faillent
que ce s'arrête mais plupart du temps de
mon fait quoi s'inquiéter le poème des
makes mais si demain premier baiser
13 12
quel était son prénom je sais pas si
vous montez oui sébastien c'est bien
vous êtes resté cinq mois en 103 vos
bonnes réponses première fois à troyes
ben ya un an
enfin on a admis première fois quatre
fois encore dix ans vous jamais pris de
drogue de ma vie n'ont jamais même pas
le nom même pas du cabanis parce qu'en
france on dit plus cannabis qui l'imposé
bravo c'était parler
le best of de la semaine mais c'est donc
puisque la semaine dernière comme vous
le savez il y avait les victoires de la
musique alors d'abord je voudrais
féliciter la petite méline l'assistante
de plateau qui a eu une petite fille
voilà qui s'appelle noah
voilà je vais faire aussi un droit de
réponse lors de la dernière émission
bruno solo a dit qu'à l'époque où il
faisait des petits boulots il écrivait
des fausses lettres pour un journal qui
s'appellent union va pas du tout le
journal s'appelait charme parce que chez
union n'y a pas de fausses lettres
d'ailleurs il suffit d'aller dans leurs
bureaux pour vérifier qu'il ya des
vraies lettres voilà alors bruno solo
est désolé d'avoir confondu charmer et
union il me demande de présenter ses
excuses au journal l'union
voilà c'est fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous regarder cette émission elle
est au théâtre des champs elysées
nominée pour le césar du meilleur second
rôle féminin pour un film qui s'appelle
harry un ami qui vous veut du bien
c'est pour ça que nous avons dû
exceptionnellement enregistré cette
émission voici mathilde seigner
[Applaudissements]
monia regardez combien
chagall
[Musique]
là on va très bien donc à l'heure où les
gens voient cette émission peut-être
vous serez titulaire d'un césar
peut-être peut-être ou pas vous avez
vous habiller comme ça samedi soir en
pull fois c'est pas bien si c'est parce
que vous connaissez laurent baffie ouais
donc après vénus beauté institut film de
tonie marshall c'était un film important
pour vous mais aussi pour nathalie baye
pour samuel le bihan
c'est un film qui a beaucoup aidé les
gens qui jouaient dedans vous avez reçu
28 scénario vous en avez choisi 6 mai
alain que vous vouliez particulièrement
pas rater justement c'était harry bien
sûr tout de suite je n'ai pas tellement
seront pas du tout rond ps que c'était
un film important la saison précédente
alors dans ce film vous est clair une
femme de tête
merde trois gamines et qui défend son
couple contre la banalité du quotidien
et puis aussi contre l'intrusion de
sergi lopez qui est en extase devant les
talents cachés de laurent lucas
d'ailleurs en parlant de laurent lucas
il n'est pas nominé lui oui justement je
trouve c'est pas très normal
ouais voilà donc sont les gens qui
votent mais je sais très anglais
engueuler les gens qui le veut non non
non non je trouve je trouve ça très
bizarre c'est un des oubliés des césars
et ce métier parfois très injuste et
sous ça curieux parce qu'il a le rôle
principal
c'est cergy et laurent donc il ya moi
c'est très gentille à sophie guillemin
c'est très gentiment fin a priori c'est
le rendre avant les autres voilà vous
dirai ça me dit ça quand vous irez
chercher votre sésame si j'osais je
dirais que oui c'est normal je vais
essayer d'être sobre bien alors on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble pour ceux
qui n'ont pas vu parce qu'elle n'a
encore qui l'ont pas vu mais bien sûr
rien à 58 millions magnéto serge paterna
rouge comme ça ça frère michel toi ça te
plaît c'est rouge commence à moi pas
s'acheter une voiture
c'est moi qui vous l'achète présente non
non non non je t'arrête tout de suite
sur deux questions c'est bon je dois pas
pourquoi
pourquoi ne pas ce que c'est
disproportionné
voilà c'est disproportionné écoute moi
je crois qu'à chaque problème une fois
une solution
une voiture est spacieuse avec la
colline c'est une première solution
les enfants de la place les parents
aussi c'est un premier pas vers une
ambiance plus détendue diraison pas
c'est pas la question c'est impossible
c'est tout moi j'étais dit que c'est
très possible
toi tu trouve ça énorme mais c'est très
relatif
- série on n'avait pas une voiture comme
ça personne peut accepter un cadeau
pareil par à peine un disque voilà alors
on les casse et le revoilà bon on vous
souhaite la meilleure chance possible
offre du prochain sort en salles un
autre film où vous jouez vous savez
comment on fait
c'est pas ma promo on n'a pas parlé de
mathias moi je veux bien le faire et on
n'est pas obligé de le faire ça ce truc
hein c'est tout le monde le fait mais
moi j'ai pas tout le monde mais mon
seigneur di falco la religion tout de
suite non mais j'attaquerai la religion
alors le film en question s'appelle la
chambre des magiciennes c'est écrit et
réalisé par claude miller
donc il ya vous il ya un brochet annie
noël yves jacques edouard baer alors
millaire dit en parlant du film c'est un
drame comique
oui c'est ça c'est juste juste non parce
que ces trois femmes dans une chambre
d'hôpital a lancé a priori c'est pas
très engageant personne n'ira donc c'est
on rit quoi voilà alors ça se passe
effectivement dans une chambre d'hôpital
et dans le cabinet d'un neurologue le
docteur fiche alors le pivot central du
film c'est pas vous hein c'est un
brochet ses cadres en principe à
trentenaire toujours étudiante en
anthropologie là des parents médiocre un
amant marié
elle somatise beaucoup elle a des
migraines dont on ne connaît pas
l'origine et lui le docteur fiche donc
décidé de l'hospitaliser
et elle se retrouve en observation dans
une chambre dit la chambre des
magiciennes avec eléonore une sorcière
autistes cloué au lit il fait le pitre
avec place là vous rendez compte que ça
très très bien et alors vous jouez
odette une espèce de téléphages
paralytique suite à une énième fausse
couche 1 et alors parfois le temps d'un
éclair
eléonore se lève comme ça pour accomplir
des miracles se livrer à des actes
violents
tous les magazines télé voilà c'est
affreux pour des essais de clerc donc
étant hospitalisé l'as s'intéresse aux
pouvoirs occultes de cette eléonore elle
oublie son égocentrisme et finalement
elle s'ouvre à autrui et cela conduit à
la guérison
bravo et c'est pas des pizzas si vous
n'êtes même pas la peine d'aller voir le
film
je devais faire pictures c'est un boulot
pictures c'est sage un contrat pas aussi
bien voilà moi j'essaie de raconter le
plus simplement possible maman on va
regarder
oui j'aurais sera aussi bien non plus
donc vous avez quoi anthropologie et vos
parents qui payent d'un petit peu et
aures et l'état finalement c'est un peu
moi qui paie vos études quelqu'un
d'assez superficiel en définitive ah bon
je les intéressais pas grand chose qui
m'intéresse le plus en ce moment c'est
moi la nouvelle compagne de ma femme
donc vous allez de la compote de pommes
comment vous trouvez nulle je peux rien
à veretout sent mauvais la nourriture de
ces mois fait chanter très bon coeur
c'est quoi ce plan c'est pour toi tu as
trouvé une nouvelle maîtresse bonjour
madame
si vous me parliez un peu de vos
compagnes de chant marché part de l'adam
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit là
personne ne pourra jamais le dire des
précisions j'ai peur
voilà la chambre des magiciennes le
commissaire saby le prix de la critique
internationale au festival de berlin en
2e en 2001 c'est un film qui est
formidable c'est un film qui est très
très bien écrit très très bien joué
non non mais c'est bien écrit on c'est
drôle et puis c'est un film qui est
intéressant mais c'est il faut dire que
c'est un film particulier a pas dire que
c'est pas la vérité si je mens quoi bon
donc faut pas vendre n'importe quoi ça
sent le 28
bien alors là vous savez on arrive à la
fiche 69 et quand on arrive à la fiche
69 et une nouvelle tradition dans cette
émission que vous ne connaissez pas
parce que tu avais en tête bêche
garderie justement en inverse les rôles
absolument le rend très bien compris
c'est une nouvelle tradition les rôles
sont inversés maintenant c'est vous qui
me poser une question à moi je les lui
je l' ai vu qu est ce qu elle est si bas
est-ce que tu va aux [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
et en plus ouais comme une conne je
répète répond toile non non non
et quitte à vue j'ai conclu j'aurais
peut-être dans ce conflit ça c'est parce
que j'ai pas fait la promo de sa pièce
donc on va le faire tout de suite
bon alors cette pièce il fait une pièce
j'ai oublié d'en parler effectivement
garde le sourire
moi non plus il fait beau alors cette
pièce laurent et ben ça marche très bien
et d'avoir à vous dire aux gens de venir
au gymnase on voit là oui on leur a
tellement envie que ces plaintes sexy
mazouni la culture générale vous
connaissez pas tout un programme
on sait bien c'est très rigolo non mais
je vais y aller michel drucker a
beaucoup aimé philippe bouvard a
beaucoup aimé jacques martin a beaucoup
fait mais bien jacques pradel a beaucoup
fait mais alors ans et daniel rieber
t'emmerde
[Musique]
combien de films que vous avez tourné
qu'ils vont sortir ou à tourner et vous
arrêtez pas à voix haute müller avec
sandrine kiberlain années quand garcia
edouard baer aux en berne ont toujours
fraîche et le deuxième c'est le film
avec michel serrault hirondelle a fait
le printemps d'un jeune metteur en scène
où je une agricultrice et après je vais
jouer là sans gêne ne riez pas j'attends
ça avec impatience
madame sans gêne on m'a proposé ça je
pense que des thénardier c'est pourquoi
apparemment tous les cas répond votre
franc-parler vous a pas vous n'êtes pas
handicaper important que ça me rire oui
votre agent et vous disais toujours fais
gaffe à ce que tu dis j'aimerais y dix
ans et je continue bon finalement mais
je fais plus attention ouais ouais ouais
ouais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui là c'est
bien moi j'ai fait la vis de son comique
j'ai fait rire de tout ce que vous aviez
dit il et vicieux et dit je n'aime pas
prendre débattront au bain douche
oui les américains
j'ai pas envie d'aller faire la [ __ ]
dans leurs films james bond c'est un jeu
vidéo pour décérébrés et oui enfin la
[ __ ] dans leur film c'est à dire qu'en
fait les rôles de français sont souvent
inintérêt cinéma intello envie parce que
vous avez dit cinéma intello the lady
que j'aime pas le cinéma et au théâtre
j'aime pas je n'ai pas entendu compte de
la ville et arrache était fiché
méfie-toi jamais un truc là alors les
actrices vous avez dit c'est la mode des
brune cheveux coupés courts avec des
tranches à boutons tu débutes c'était
bon mais ça vous coûte rien en même
temps non si c'est pas bien parce que ça
ressort les acteurs finir les acteurs de
l'e 10
vous avez dit en parlant des jeunes
acteurs c'est tout c'est fitch
qu'on arrête il va nous dire c'est fini
en parlant des acteurs c'est des plus
jeunes acteurs français c'est des ploucs
immonde
j'ai dit ça ouais bah oui non pas
généralisée qui par exemple est un peu
parce que sont pas tous comme ça
cite moi un an donc et pas comme ça
manquer comme ça que je annonc et pas
comme ça ce que alors qu'il n'est pas
non plus un delon et revenons aux
acteurs en plus le cas vous êtes un peu
calmés quand même oui oui enfin bon je
suis un an vous dites du mal d'internet
quoi c'est plus c'est moins en moins de
risques
ce que je voulais dire alors vous
acceptez toujours pas les scènes de nu
un nom
j'accepte plus parce que je précise que
j'ai dans le sourire j'avais fait une
scène une petit strip teaseuse est-ce
que sid magnéto serge vous aviez fait un
casting un peu traumatisant et
ça vous avait choqué non traumatisant
non mais pour un film c'était un film
porno en fait c'était une filiale de
civières filière fille alors il ya eu le
premier film effectivement le sourire
donc vous avez bu huit cognac avant de
tourner la cenal strip tease bissau est
vrai j'étais saoul tellement que j'y
suis allée quoi et sans figure encore
fait danser toute nue devant cent
figurants
j'ai c'était dur oh la la il n'en est
pas un ouvrage vous avez une doublure
vous n'êtes plus de scènes de nu heures
non mais ça vous choque parce que vous
avez dit quand quand j'étais petit je
manger un sandwich sur la plage il y
avait des nudistes et je n'arrivais plus
à manger mon sandwich mais c'est à ce
point là les gérants il était sur la
plage ils avaient leurs lampes qui
trempés comme des couteaux mais j'avais
7 ans quoi j'étais jeune le blocage
alors grave il ya neuf ans tu t'écoutes
m'ont libéré par rapport complètement
tue pas et alors vous dites mais ça mes
fesses je les montre à mon fiancé
exactement de celui qui les voient oui
[Musique]
à bord
la chance bien ou c'est ce qu'on va
faire là non une interview qu'on n'a
jamais faites
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle même
mois personne n'aime voir caler
je veux pas que je bouge je l'avais dis
moi qui tu veux pas que je bouge pour
notre jean gol d'accord dire et je te
respecte je bougerai pas pendant le
jingle l'évêché ans si l'on touche parle
plus de lui mais je n'en comprends
ohlala alors vous allez voir c'est une
nouvelle interview qui l'interviewent
sans peur et sans reproche et sans
reproche est ce que dans la vie vous
êtes plutôt comme ça
[Musique]
choisir le chat
ou comme ça alors maman besoin de
personne très bien voilà je vois que
mathilde décennies on a bien fait de
commencer avec vous vous avez compris
tout de suite comment ça fonctionne
c'est pas très difficile plein de gens
qui auraient mis un moment à comprendre
maintenant j'en vois passer moi toute
l'année vous savez des connards ici a
raison c'est vrai la turquie par exemple
[Rires]
alors pour vous la vie c'est plutôt noir
ou bien voilà noir c'est noir comme est
quand même bien g amour parce que je
préfère dire ni c'est alors en amour
vous êtes plutôt comme ça
[Musique]
chan
ou comme ça arrive
il met touche bas ni l'un ni l'autre
avantage c'est à dire alors je suis dit
arrête arrête ne me touche pas ni c'est
quoi l'autre alors les hommes vous les
préférez comme ça
[Musique]
ou bien comme ça
[Applaudissements]
ni macho ni sexy boy pour vous l'amour
c'est ça c'est un bon moment s'est tu
[Musique]
ou c'est ça
j'avais
non fugain fuga très bien quand même
vous aimeriez vivre ou là la montagne
de là la mère
non oula d'arrivée
faire à merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a loupé gelé alors oui alors beaucoup
d'emails beaucoup d'emails encore cette
semaine
énormément d'imagés cette semaine
notamment au sujet de sa jeune choses
qui arrivent gêne pas que quand dans vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabanis déjà fumé du cannabis vont
jamais ah bon je n'ai jamais fumé
quelques joints une fois c'est toi et ça
m'a pas réussi ça bon bien alors michaël
blanc lui valent un peu de fumée on sait
pas en tous les cas il est en taule à
bali il s'est fait serrer pour pour
toujours à perpétuité du cabanis pour du
cabinet civil avec un comité de soutien
dont je vais donner le site assez
www.michaeljackson.com
ww points mickaël tir et blanc pointent
comme pour avoir des nouvelles
ou pour l'aider voilà faut l'aider le
mec dans tout le pour toute sa vie mais
c'est absurde
ouais mais ils sont comme ça là bas
voilà j'ai reçu un email de son bac ce
qui me dit c'est sympa d'aidé michaël
blanc mais tu pourrais quand même
rappeler mon cher thierry que en france
dans notre beau pays pour un joint on
prend un an tu savais toi mais tu as
fait combien de préventive toi c'est ton
jour un joint et 20 ans pour trafic
moi ça c'est normal je m'en réjouis
trafic de joie vingt ans c'est beaucoup
quand même
bon je parlais de cabanis mais des
ravages au quotien ya le hb très
dangereux le hachage et le croque aussi
et roanne alors amoureuse may cry le cab
à nice a été dépénalisée en belgique en
hollande en espagne mais aussi au
portugal
ça je savais pas et pourtant ce n'est
pas une monarchie dit parce que moi je
disais que cabanis et est dépénalisée
dans les monarchies alors la fédération
des cirques
alors ça c'est des gens qu'il milite
pour la légalisation du cabanis il se
félicite de la nomination de bernard
kouchner la santé parce que en 1976
bernard kouchner avait signé l'appel du
18 juin en faveur de la légalisation
donc ils disent maintenant qu'il est
ministre il va peut-être nous aider
voilà bernard on en parlera avec
christine ockrent tout à l'heure elle va
venir
la vie est belle dans la loge avait
déchaîné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous vous intéressez au
football ah non non ça tombe bien voici
luis fernandez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
c'est à l'est c'est pas comme un parc
des princes là c'est beaucoup plus sympa
comme par pl1 s'est toujours plaint pas
d'abord et c'est là mais j'applaudis - à
10 heures de temps bien ça va en fait
tout le monde parle de vous c'est pour
ça que vous êtes là je vous remercie
d'être là parce que l'expo n'est pas
très souvent depuis quelques temps je
vous remercie d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle alors le 3 décembre 2000
après une défaite à 1,5 contre sedan le
président du psg laurent perpère limoges
l'entraîneur philippe bergeron qui avait
remplacé alain giresse qu'elle était lui
aussi viré et fait appel à vous et
c'était la fin de votre atteint poste
très délicat très délicat c'est la fin
de notre année sabbatique et on parlait
de vous pour l'om et vous êtes venu donc
au psg alors dès que vous arrivez au psg
om et autres et autres dès que vous
arrivez au psg vous multipliez les
déclarations d'amour pour les joueurs
pour le dirigeant pour le public vous
redonner espoir à tout le monde
malheureusement les résultats n'ont pas
suivi et on dit aujourd'hui l'effet
fernandes n'a pas joué y a pas que lui
qui peut jouer ou bien alors 3 pelli dur
alors pas dire c'est louise non mais
l'autrichien défend mais c'est qu'il
n'apprécie pas plus que ça ça va
s'agrandir dans l'internet
pas du tout bon ça c'est pas vrai je
l'aï présenté dans les couloirs et
appelle le baltringue baba comment ça se
traduit à l'antenne avant l'été dit un
peu la température variant d'un temps
qui passe du bon côté il sait qu'il peut
prendre un coup de boule en même temps
il va essayer de gérer tout ça non mais
bon c'est la réalité que je raconte la
trois victoires en 15 matches dont une
contre eux que contre thouars sait même
pas que ça existait là vous avez gagné
national 3e division qui est 32e de la
coupe deux ans en 3e division du
national avait d'accord mais c'est en
jouant sur la route alors donc voilà
alors dans la ligue des champions et le
match aller contre milan ac 1-1 et
samedi dernier il ya eu marseille 0-1
0-1 et année mardi le retour de milan ac
à a
c'est ça un vrai pont on va voir une
tête formidable moi je trouve là dans le
match mardi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
ça alors le résoudre ce problème là pour
trouver la solution d'instinct des
solutions louer sérieusement c'est un
beau match laurent robert il avait pu
marquer depuis le 2 décembre un quart
d'heure de la fin voilà
mais il ya eu josé maría dernière minute
oui mais je crois que dans l'ensemble on
peut être satisfait moi personnellement
j'ai été satisfait de la prestation des
joueurs je crois qu'a longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu jouer l'équipe de la
sorte en y mettant de la qualité en
émettant du un état d'esprit on retrouve
en certaines choses qu'on avait perdu
ces derniers temps comme tu l'as si bien
dit dans tes des fiches
ouais il ya longtemps un et bon bah tu
sais il faut mettre un certain temps
pour retrouver une équipe l'ont essayé
de diverses et j'y suis pour je suis là
pour ça alors l'avenir c'est le quart de
finale alors là il faut faire un sans
faute là parce que il ya la corogne le 7
mars et galatasaray le 13 mars il faut
gagner les deux matches c'est possible
ça c'est jouable
s'ils jouent à je crois que c'est
possible il ya le suspense avait
énormément et c'est toujours bon d'y
croire on va regarder
actuellement il ya un adversaire qui est
la corogne qui est a priori difficile
ouais mais en football on peut toujours
penser renversé on peut y arriver parce
qu'il reste plus que ça le haut niveau
hexagonal éliminé de la coupe de france
son 16e de finale coupe de la ligue
coupe de la ligue
voilà un championnat 12e sur 18
appareils un relégué en d2 non je crois
pas je crois que l'équipe a suffisamment
de qualité de fierté et d'orgueil pour
pour s'en sortir bien luis fernandes la
france veut en savoir plus
interview vérité
[Musique]
une
fêtes au chaud laurent baffie des gens
souhaitent déchiré la gueule là pas du
tout je les ai vus j'aime bien je le
préviens alors non pas du tout luis en
96 vous déclariez à l'équipe magazine
j'attendrai le temps qu'il faudra mais
je suis convaincu que je reviendrai au
psg aujourd'hui vous regretter d'être
venu au projet fort hills quelque part
quelque chose que je ne l'avais pensé je
l'avais imaginé peut-être pas si
rapidement que ça ouais parce que après
avoir passé quatre années comme celle
que j'ai pas sur l'espagne avoir vécu
dans un championnat comme le championnat
espagnol
je m'étais donné une année sabbatique un
peu et dans le dans ce monde qui est un
peu un monde et le milieu du football
qui a énormément bougé
il ya beaucoup de choses qui qui bouge
maintenant pour la porte n'était pas
alors non je rejette pas du tout c'est
un club que j'aime et que fait partie de
moi
alors est ce que vous vivez la plus
mauvaise période de votre carrière
d'entraîneur non non non parce qu'il ya
il ya des moments difficiles c'est
éventuellement à la télé ça arrive aussi
un oui mais dans les 8 années
d'entraîneur depuis le début
parfois j'ai eu des moments difficiles
et que bon bah les gens ne sont pas
censés savoir ne pas connaître
à moi de bien savoir les passer ces
moments là et pourquoi le psg gagne plus
en fait pour qu'ils ne gagnent plus le
pg je crois qu'il ya eu quand on voit un
peu la situation du club et on voit un
peu ces dix dernières années à chaque
année il ya toujours un une période un
peu délicate
un peu difficile et le club a toujours
ce mauvais passage et qu'on n'arrive pas
à relativement à essayer de trouver la
solution à moi et je pense que
personnellement j'ai quelques idées
là-dessus bien
alors quand lors de la défaite le 10
février à auxerre vous avez déclaré que
c'est peut-être de la malchance vais
parler de corbeaux et de chats noirs et
c'est avec le 20 février contre le milan
ac
égalisation à la dernière minute il ya
un mauvais sort contre le psg je ne
dirais pas qui est un mauvais sort il ya
un an on peut dire que dans le sport il
ya des périodes comme ça qu'il faut
savoir analyser qu'il faut savoir
essayer de comprendre même si parfois on
essaie de se dire bon on a trouvé une
solution mais que le football le sport
en général il n'y a rien d'acquis mais
que ça aussi ça fait partie dans le
football de ces moments difficiles
qu'une équipe peut travers d'un mauvais
sort parce que laurent ruquier a essayé
de désenvoûter le psg dans son émission
mardi dernier il a presque réussi il a
presque réussi
il a presque réussi nous serons à nu
alors il a presque réussi parce qu'on a
fait un bon match face à milan ouais il
on dirait je dirais plutôt que c'est sur
ces matches là qu'on travaille un peu
sourd pour l'avenir ouais
pour en revenir à la ligue des champions
compte tenu des performances actuelles
de l'équipe
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que ses
deux victoires en deux matches sont
possibles
oui oui oui tout est possible je dirais
que quand on voit l'équipe réalisé de
bons matches face au milan ac
ouais en y mettant de la qualité en y
mettant un état d'esprit on dit que la
coupe d'europe ça c'est un parfum un peu
spécial ça les joueurs aiment cette
compétition là ils la jouent parce
qu'ils savent que c'est un peu la
vitrine c'est à dire que ces joueurs là
du psg ils se battent que quand c'est
des trucs un peu valorisant encore la
ligue des champions ça c'est
c'est que je pense qu'avec des champions
ça transforme ça motive ça s'est passé
s'est regardé dans le monde entier on a
tous en guinée avec des champions c'est
la coupe d'europe c'est le c'est un des
objectifs
bon c'était peut-être pas celui du pg
cette année c'était peut-être derrière
en quarts de finale ouais alors il faut
éventuellement il faut aussi à une fois
à la corogne contre la corogne avec le
psg sens et je sais que vous dites on
peut y arriver on peut y arriver
ouais non c'est parce que j'ai gagné
là-bas c'est que je crois que l'effectif
où l'équipe pour en réalisant ce qu'elle
a réalisé cette année tant elle est
capable de gagner à la corogne skis sont
pas trop payés trop gâté les joueurs du
psg aujourd'hui je ne dirais pas je ne
dirais pas comme ça je dirais que le
football en depuis la loi bosman depuis
le sait ces changements c'est d'un étang
et à un bouleversement des données et il
faudrait s'y pencher mais bon ce sont
des artistes des garçons qui essaye de
faire le mieux possible si on est con on
est trop payé dans le milieu du football
je dirais que dans d'autres professions
si on est trop pire réellement mercredi
expressif regarde bien pour quoi vous
changer si souvent luis la formation de
l'équipe stobart et quand énormément de
compétition contient un effectif surtout
quand on a comme celui que tu as la main
tu as 20 à 25 joueurs qui sont également
où il ya de la qualité
tu es obligé de faire un tour 9 heures
l'entraîneur nantais reynald et nos ex
le disais il ya pas très longtemps
pourtant il est deuxième du championnat
avec des options de gagner la coupe de
france la coupe de la ligue il en coupe
d'europe il est en championnat alors il
est dans le vrai et je pense aussi comme
lui que quand tu as beaucoup de
compétition il faut aussi penser à faire
tourner un peu ton effigie alors quand
tu gagnes personnes l'avaient lary le
nom pas et quand tu perds ça change
alors quand on parle maintenant on va te
dire aussi sur la tactique tu changes
souvent de système tactique tu joues
avec 3 avec 4 avec ça avec les joueurs
sont un peu perdus mais ils sont censés
être professionnel aussi le joueur doit
s'adapter à toutes les situations
est ce que l'entraîneur doit s'adapter
ci contre le milan ac je m'aperçois que
je joue dans un système et que ça se
passe mal à moins d'interpréter le jeu à
moi de changer et le jour est capable
d'analyser qu'il faut changer le joueur
a su le faire face à milan c'est parce
que ça qu'en ce moment on rentre un peu
dans c dans ses systèmes et les médias
veulent savoir aussi quand je les vois à
la télé sur le banc de touche c'est un
vrai spectacle avec eux de le voir et
parce qu'en tout cas il est normal dès
son match et il a l'air sincère dans ce
qu'il fait là l'image qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure là c'était une magnifique
l'aller le visage détruit par le monde
et je suis détruit
ça fait mal pour les jours parce qu'ils
le méritent pas un mérite pas de prendre
un but comme ça à la minute
quand on voit ce qu'ils ont réalisé
durant 90 autant je peux être déçu après
le match de guingamp
ouais de la deuxième mi temps lorsqu'on
perd 3 à la maison je peux être déçu
parce que parce que ces comportements
peut-être il ya eu un relâchement mais
après une défaite après un match nul
comme suit
face au milan quand on prend un but tout
ça et luiz mais qui prend la place de
mai pour le psg un match nul en ce
moment c'est pour apprendre et parce que
j'ai vu quelque part tous les soirs
quand il commence il dit encore un jour
sans que le pg et gagner à l'essai du
récent alors est-ce que pourquoi vous
nous obligez pas anelka parler à la
presse
les médias se sont acharnés un peu sonné
quand là je jouerai mon
dire que nicolas c'est quand on le
connaît bien quand on le voit vivre au
sein d'un groupe
c'est quelqu'un de très des charmants il
est il est sympa il est en plus de
s'attirer des solutions qui profite à
qui oui mais alors justement
contrairement à ça quand ils vendent
espagne qui fait un contrat de sept ans
il n'a pas eu revenir un an après au
paris saint-germain parce qu'il peut
rester ces temps là bas et
éventuellement il peut se mettre
vraiment tranquillement mais jusqu'à la
fin de ses jours
ouais pour te dire ce qu'il a laissé la
voie pour revenir jouer en france
footballeur parce que les artistes non
je pense moi - car il ya beaucoup plus
longue
la nôtre est resté carrière qui s'étend
sur une dizaine d'années
mais on n'en gagne que pendant cinq six
ans sinon les cinq premières années tous
ne viennent presque aux tarifs ils ont
acquis le savoir
l'année prochaine si vous n'êtes pas bon
ça ne suffisait pas en coupe d'europe
les garder anelka quand même oui bon il
fait partie de ces garçons sur lesquels
on compte je crois que c'est bien le
moins pour lui non ici à paris c'est
quand même un grand club
quand même impressionnant est un club
qui fait rêver claverie en europe
quand on parle du passionnément en
espagne c'est un club qui aspire à être
hyper considéré en espagne d'une bonne
cote cote annoncer l'évangile c'est vrai
connu cette année jean jacques sept mois
et a pas de problème bien est ce que
laurent perpère et compétents comme les
crises très compétent a vraiment ce que
l'on peut dire ce que j'ai les meilleurs
que denisot comme président ira comme ça
je dirais qu'il est différent il a sa
méthode perpère et quand même quelqu'un
qui laisse travailler son entraîneur et
qui le laisse faire ce qu'il a à faire
et que il nous laisse travailler
tranquillement
alors les supporteurs ils sont pas
contents 1 je les ai rencontrés a pas
très longtemps sont pas contents ils ont
rencontré un banderole ils ont fait une
banderole avec ww point équipe de merde
point fr c'est quand même mais bon ça
c'est le
c'est un peu le et puis sur le tard sur
la route du camp des loges quelques
temps les un peu capables match avancé
du d'annette sur la voiture du père perd
aussi oui aux anelka qui prend aussi la
sueur d'année mais le présent père
perrière et vous allez rencontrer
j'ai bien la rencontre des supporters ce
qui n'est réellement c'est souvent rien
à qui ce qui se cache et crèches et
qu'est ce qu'il leur a dit le président
fait ensemble on s'est retrouvé avec 300
400 supporters on leur expliquait on
leur a donné des raisons de bon vin que
la situation n'était pas au mieux ouais
c'est normal qu'ils soient déçus mais il
faut qu'on reste solidaire pour qu on
reste unis la bourse enceintes et autres
suicides de 13 % quand je les supporters
qu'il faudrait quand même verrouillé
l'histoire maintenant on verra bien bien
alors maintenant chez vous vous éteignez
la lumière et je réponds alors en un
style pas la télé si un mec qui me dit
quand on fait la question qui tue on
éteint la lumière est ce qu'on doit
éteindre la télé non en est un que la
lumière laurent est ici aussi
[Musique]
voilà c'est chaud la conception nous
islandaise serez-vous encore entraîneur
du psg la saison prochaine
jusqu'à preuve du contraire oui même si
vous perdez tous les matches qui
viennent là je ne serais je ne souhaite
pas perdre et je pense qu'on ne perdra
pas tous les matches qui restent très on
va en gagner on va remonter on va on va
se situer dans une position qui sera un
peu plus honorable pour le pas et sa
maman et pour tous ceux qui aiment le
paillis maman merci on rallume
bien qu chamakh
maintenant on va laisser longtemps plus
les matchs du psg
prochain match le 3 mars psg toulouse et
la corogne le 7 mars donc on sera tous
devant le poste de télé pour vous
soutenir
vrai et faux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques emails pour continuer monica de
nice qui me dit thierry serait-il
possible que tu te mettes de dos
j'aimerais voir ta nuque aux biens se
contentent allumé l'ucla javier de
valence qui me dit pour éviter tout
boulette
merci de prévenir linda hardy du décès
de charles trenet et bertrand qui me dit
est ce qu'il y aura encore des émissions
ça s'en va et ça revient oui il y en a 4
avant l'été et le dit martial la nuit
gainsbourg mon cher bertrand
attention attention le petit prince du
raï est devenu le roi du raï massif aux
dead
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que là bas il a grandi faudel a
ils peuvent ils devenus grands
maintenant faudel dans c'est vrai ils
ont quand même mais il a grandi
c'est devenu un petit homme maintenant
fait d'elle merci c'est vrai alors que
dell en vous connais pour ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
baboo erp ln la chance lui dit elle
danse avec fonelle alors fait d'elle on
vous connaît aussi pour ça
[Musique]
quelques jours
on vous connaît pour sa jeu
[Musique]
mais la mesure
il est
vous savez maintenant il ya ça y est
une femme
et plus
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
joie dans la vérité si l'europe sans
bouleverser chauffeuse de salle elle
chauffe la salle elle chauffe pas que la
salle d'ailleurs bien alors qu'à alors
fenêtre quatre ans après baïda qui s'est
vendu à combien 300 400 mille
exemplaires 350 milles c'est énorme
alors maintenant il ya samra c'est le
douzième et qui est un peu le bilan des
quatre années que vous avez de vivre
ouais c'est ça cet album c'est beaucoup
d'ouverture de beaucoup de d'influencés
diverses exactement ben oui parce que
j'ai une double culture français
d'origine algérienne donc troisième
génération l'un donc j'ai mis un peu
c'est à dire quand j'ai sollicité le
producteur nabil khalidi et gotoda voilà
qui est japonais mais voilà japonais
japonais qui figure de la musique
orientale avec le japonais va exactement
donc quand je leur ai parlé j'aurais dit
ce que j'écoutais donc j'aimais bien la
salsa flamenco et ils ont fait en fait
ce que ce que je leur ai dit voilà alors
c'est donc beaucoup d'influencé
croisement de beaucoup d influence des
grosses productions est pareil à
savourer beaucoup d'argent à la maison
de disques un petit peu non anelka à la
batterie on peut pas se payer ça vous
plaît le rail mathilde oui si je vis un
ouais j'aime bien le rail pas le rap
mêlera y trouvera ya quelque chose
devrait être vraiment traditionnel c'est
la mort le thème récurrent c'est
s'il ya un beau rythme alors que le rap
tarik que moi ton touche pas ça dépend
du rap un tas de la merde des trucs bien
ah ben non d'accord même doc gynéco
surtout vu les yeux qu'il a aussi lu au
lycée très marrant parce qu'ils sont
verts en hiver et blanc n'était avait dû
pour regarder précédé lentilles et
regarde
gros plan sur mesures et plans serge
gros plan sur les yeux de faudel voilà
et maintenant gros plan sur les yeux de
fernandez pour montrer quand même
qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est une émission
beaux yeux bleu chemise bleue à la
droite qui fait un gros plan sur les
seins de maths il vous est beaucoup plus
sûr de vous dans ce moment là je trouve
plus la plus affirmée lors c'était un
peu timide au premier album c'est non
c'est normal la température mais moi qui
avais qui vient de mantes-la-jolie je
débarque ma cité j'arrive à paris
je comprends pas en fait donc quand on a
enregistré l'album je faisais ce qu'on
dit aujourd'hui sa chérie j'ai mais
c'est vrai quand vous êtes arrivé vous
étiez un peu la bête de foire non pardon
vous étiez un peu une bête de foire le
petit le petit prince du raï à voilà qui
est propre sur lui qui souffre sur les
terrains qui volent à nous aujourd'hui
donc je suis un petit peu plus sûr de
moi on va parler de vous en parler d'eux
oui
[Musique]
voilà moi je ne chante plus donc puisque
tout le monde interdit de chanter tant
pis pour vous je ne chante plus pourquoi
reims qui paraît que j'étais très
ridicule quand je chantais ma vie comme
ça en plus vous faites un peu un peu
freak chanteur elle la regarde
l'émission donc elle me l'a dit aussi
alors vos parents faudel sont venus en
france en 65 pour travailler chez
renault votre mère ensuite a fait des
ménages
vous dites ils ont pris sur ça veut dire
quoi qu'ils ont beaucoup souffert ou
beaucoup travaillé ça donne beaucoup
travaillé travaillé par ailleurs lancé
grandi à mantes la jolie cité du val
fourré qui est la plus grande d'europe
et quand même ethnie trust inc combien
25 35 et nice va mal quand même énorme
dans une ville dans la ville
ouais dans sa morale dans votre nouveau
disque vous faites une chanson sur sur
mantes la jolie
oui on dire à ceux du val fourré que je
pense toujours à eux bien sûr d'ailleurs
un bon jour ils sont pour elle et à
bonjour mantes la jolie
oui bien sûr je dis à tous mes amis de
2,2 de montjoux mantes-la-jolie et
bonjour les minguettes
non spéciale dédicace à tous les
pitbulls
vous aviez peur
j'ai peur que les gens duval pourrait
croire que vous avez réussi vous avez
oublié sa non voilà exactement c'est un
peu c'est un truc où je leur dis oui
j'ai pas changé j'ai juste évolué et
puis jamel il a le même discours
ouais c'est normal c'est bien travaillé
le pas renié ses origines sociales y'a
pas que il n'ya presque que jamel mais
bien moi j'ai recommencé ziem lagarde
tout le monde joue un nom parce que nul
n'est prophète dans son pays donc on a
un peu autre jalon justifier un peu et
voilà donc moi aujourd'hui j'ai décidé
de pas faire de concert à mantes la
jolie et cvc pour une raison c'est
qu'ils ne connaissent pas il n'y a pas
de spectacle il y en avoir quelques uns
qui connaissent déjà
alors vous avez découvert le ragga la
maison votre mère vraie rentrée du
marché avec des cassettes exactement est
les écouter en faisant la cuisine est
aussi qui vous a dit tout ça pas moi
vous avez je travaille c'est chez que
c'est assez surprenant et votre père
était contre oui papa était content
parce que lui pour lui le laura il
aurait qui était qui était produit dans
des cabarets dans des lieux un peu
malsain et c'est à dire qu'il voulait
pas trop que que je que que je verrai
vérité il n'avait pas vous finissez
comme khaled n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent
donc non en fait il n'était pas trop
d'accord parce que à 15 ans d'aller dans
l'est dans les bars de chanter dans les
noms ils voulaient pas évolué que je
suis mes études et alors en fait ce qui
s'est passé si vous à lille était en
vacances en algérie at elle l'a fait
avec votre grand mère qui chantait
pendant l'annoncé une chanteuse
traditionnelle qui s'appelle meeddat
voilà c'est ça hein alors l'homme les
nazis pendant la sieste et et d'oran le
pays de chanteur du raï est sous la
véranda avec des instruments distribuent
des petits instruit si tout le monde
chantait et à l'âge de 8 ans un jour
faudel fait un duo avec sa grand-mère et
c'est le déclic vous rendez compte que
ça vous donne la chair de poule vous
éprouvé quelques jours puisque ici à vay
ouais en fait je suis dit tiens je peux
faire comme elle est donc su rentrer en
france à l'autre la jolie j'ai appelé
des potes et j'ai monté mon premier
groupe sap les étoiles du rail
voilà neuf ans vous avez gagné votre
premier concours exactement à la girafe
sait où la girafe ou la synergie c'est
un autre la jeunesse ouais mais qui sait
qu'il est la chanson c'était abdelkader
exactement révoqué qui est devenu un
tube avec un deux trois soleil et voilà
ouais à 12 ans a effectivement vous
faites votre premier groupe embarqué par
votre frère qui chante aussi d'ailleurs
pas beaux lots le groupe s'appelle
étoiles du rail où il est à la grotte à
mantes la jolie et j'étais un local qui
avait été négociée avec la mairie par
momo mohamed meftah exactement voilà qui
est à l'ancien guitariste tout à fait
voilà bravo
bah ouais je m'intéresse à tout ce que
j'ai à faire et rien non ce que je veux
maintenant est ce que j'aurai qu'on dit
sérieusement c'est à quel point vous en
vouliez quand même parce que d'abord
vous l'avez c'est vrai qu'il viendrait
de manager oui bien sûr parce que
comment dirais-je g comment on
s'entendait pas j'ai arrêté avec les
avec les étoiles du raid dont je voulais
continuer c'était quelqu'un peut qui
organise et beaucoup de concerts
vraiment c'est quelqu'un qui s'est battu
pour pour mantes la jolie
donc j'ai vu un peu une structure un peu
sérieux c'est à dire elle avait un
bureau et tous et je me suis dit tiens
lui il peut s'occuper de moi il peut me
trouver des musiciens c'est comme ça qui
m'avait présenté à l'époque matthieu
chedid que les guitaristes avec moi
ouais et alors en fait au début lui
n'est pas très chaud pour donner à votre
manager mais vous l'avez tellement tanné
puis comme aux parents travaillent
ensemble en fait j'ai menti en fait j'ai
j'étais en algérie je vous dis je vais
j'ai apporté des textes et des mélodies
des chansons et je vais revenir et puis
on va faire un disque j'ai menti vais
donc avec des fois il faut mentir je
suis rentré et m'a dit alors ils sont au
chili bat g rien du tout et là il a
tellement aimé le culot mots au kilo
mais vous a demandé de vous plier à une
discipline militaire quand même bien
rigolé c'est un peu comme michael
jackson
ouais ouais oui comme il doit se plier
notre discipline avec axa non c'est vrai
si placer les autres jouent au foot et
vous vous répétiez cours de chant et au
talent et il l'a dit mon moment il a dit
faudel n'a pas eu d'adolescence c'était
comme un sportif ça qu'il a vachement
beau c'est en fait aujourd'hui je crois
je regrette pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui avec je remercie la vie et
mes parents j'ai eu une éducation
superbe et merci maman merci papa et
voilà il rêvait d'une eau destinée pour
vous vos parents quand même quand même
sont très fiers mais je pense me déjà
arrivé que vous soyez fonctionnaires qui
voulait un peu que j'ai à l'école que je
suis mes études
voilà aujourd'hui je crois que comme on
dit la télé c'est un impact énorme quand
il m'a vu la première fois la télé les
studios est si sérieuse mais aussi avec
nos mots que vous avez signé avec
mercury ils ont trouvé ça sérieux quand
même
ouais non à l'époque c'était un label
s'appelait sankara oui si les tunnels de
mercure est tout à fait gagnée monté par
constantin a dû et sont là mais avec big
ok je sais plus où le cac france 2
maintenant je regarde ce que je voulais
dire on n'en rien c'est vos parents qui
quand ils vous ont vu signé voilà que il
le raconte 13 rue desbureaux sérieux et
toi qu'il y avait vraiment des gens
sérieux
et puis lundi ses partisans alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes une star
non je crois pas vous êtes au musée
grévin ah oui paraît aussi la wii dans
toutes les boîtes et un quart d'heure de
raï maintenant vous êtes l'intégration
ça me casse les bonbons
ouais puisque je ne fais pas je ne suis
pas je m'intègre pas jeune français
d'origine vite quand je vais en algérie
je suis pas chez moi ici je suis pas
vraiment chez moi tout à fait nous les
jeunes de banlieue on est forcément
perturbé la troisième génération et vous
souffrons encore de ça je crois oui
aujourd'hui où un petit peu quand même
je crois on n'est pas perturbé mais mais
mais il ya quand même quelque chose qui
est qui va pas je crois je crois que le
mène de banlieue de quartier je crois
qu'on a d'avoir vécu pour l'avoir connu
on a automatiquement n'a fait on a
parqué alors qu'on aurait pu
sensibiliser à l'art et des beaucoup
plus proche
proche de cette jeunesse être les
responsabiliser être là à porter et il y
avait des solutions et je crois que
c'est de jeunesse aujourd'hui elle est
une difficulté on la ressent je
pousserai que dans ces banlieues dans
ses cartes et comme on est toujours les
gens hyper intéressant à des gens qui
ont beaucoup envie de faire des choses
intéressantes et de se montrer aussi que
dans la société ont aussi leur place
il faudra quand même qu'à l'époque
habiter dans une cité c'était du grand
standing à l'époque c'était en 1965
souverain s'était trop standing parce
que tu avais un petit centre commercial
à côté tu avais l'école et il ya un
petit parc pour les enfants donc c'était
c'était lui qui avait la première
poubelle où tu ne descendait pas en bas
de l'époque
vous êtes croyants ouais je vois bien
bien bien sûr qu'un jour les ascenseurs
vont re marché ouais tu aies croisé mais
vous n'êtes pas directement aux
appartements
vous n'êtes pas pratiquants non fais pas
le ramadan
non je n'aime pas l'alcool vous en buvez
de temps en temps une coupe de champagne
puisque le malais nous a expliqué que la
religion musulmane est autorisé 10 et de
boire sauf pour prier alors j'ai reçu
plein de l'e-mail qui disait mais pas du
tout il faut jamais voir pardon j'ai pas
dit le contraire madame oui et non non
mais rallye sans voix légèrement
républicains pour bien mais ce n'est
guère
c'est un père d un
le siècle la première fois c'était à 14
ans avec une rue pleine de 16 ans 1
wallah exactement ces permis ça sinon on
appelle ça zina et s'est dépêché est ce
que le fleur qu'on a droit que le
tchador ou pas
confer légion toutes les religions c'est
idiot danger mois dans le bouddhisme
droite c'est bien sûr s'entretenir en
direct donc soin d'elle la première fois
donc c'était avec une européenne vous
aviez 14 ans c'est avec une européenne
de 16 ans vous l'avez jamais vu la fille
qui l'a l'européenne les jeunes
était ce qu'il y a dit sa mère jusqu'à
deux ans après il va voir sa mère du
bambin brantus et maintenant je suis un
homme je me suis tapé gonzesses et tous
complices avec nous mêmes avec la capote
vous aviez peur qu'elle soit enceinte sa
fille et pourtant vous aviez la cape les
fidèles c'est vrai c'est vrai alors il
va voir je suis maman sa mère et lui dit
non maintenant je suis un homme et tout
ce merdier d'amis la capote au moins
huit mamans c'est ça mais nous on fait
bon qui a pris cette grande aventure
avec séverine ferrer sans capote risque
est ce que c'est à cause de vous que
vous êtes allé voir le dalaï lama jeu
d'ailleurs bonjour séverine non non non
on a vécu des belles choses
donnez-vous de très belles choses très
belles choses un peu de temps en temps
et tout va bien je sais qu'elle est une
offense à l'est de l'ariège non si cela
s'est très bien
alors aujourd'hui vous allez trouver
l'âme soeur non faut lancer un appel
alors on va là c'est la peine regardez
votre caméra mais on sait que là où
saute on a trouvé plein de julie 6 pour
les gens qui parlent de rennes avait
toujours avec la russie pendant est ce
que ça tient
c'est mieux incorrigible investissements
cherche quoi tu demandes c'est bon j'ai
envie d'apprendre le show zaoui et
toutous moi je ne voulais pas qu'elle
soit 22 printemps
vous m'en voyez des images je ferai
suivre un modèle mais je t'ai vu une
fois que j'aurais jeté vieux ou quoi la
photo avec
il avait même deux ans j'ai onze en plus
pas moins témoin des vieilles j'ai 30
ans et plus j'ai trente trois mois
rencontre bon bon bon apport du moment
qu'elle est mignonne joly a pas de j'ai
pas de préférence pas trop con il faut
dire qu'on est à dire sans champignon
imprécises c'est un média et le livre
de voir yvan
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les pas de surprise
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas comme un
jingle
[Musique]
moi
et
[Musique]
bien c'est l'interview dernier coup
maintenant et b4 bull a laissé pour ça
ah oui c'est ça
bon vous êtes prêt faudel de quoi bas à
l'interview l'interview dernier coup est
parti dernier coup dur mort de charles
trenet c'est un parent à vous devant
dernier coup de tête
foot au foot je mets à edge et marqué un
but
on cherche des gens qui m'arrivait
veulent prendre ses marques et une
charge de 80 ans avait déjà là encore je
cherche des buts je suis le meilleur
comment avez-vous simplement ils
marquent contre leur camp ils ont ils
cherchent des buteurs c'est payé 300
millions bon dernier coup de coeur alors
l'un des coups de coeur ont aussi un
album ne peut dire qui bah oui julien
clerc ah oui si j'étais elle bel et bien
celle là j'aime bien le fait mieux que
toi on se console faudel on se concentre
dernier coup de poing le mouchard nous
violons je ne suis pas crédible quand je
suis athée une patate
ouais je sais pas j'ai jamais vu un
dernier coup de folie dans les coups de
folie je cherchais une porsche c'est
bien j'ai acheté une maison à ma maman à
bien dernier coup de foudre
coup de foudre séverine ferrer séverine
ferrer
alalalala et vous la regretter un peu
savent en faire un nom
dernier coup de fil coup de fil
j'ai demandé l'adresse de ton studio
ouais voilà voilà dernier coup de rouge
c'est un petrus 82 aulas a fait trois
pas souvent mais quand ils boivent c'est
du bon dernier coup de bluff sang du
christ dernier coup de bluff
bon là j'ai dû moi j'ai blessé
maman parce que je l'invité manger un
couscous le dimanche et et je lui ai dit
en fait j'ai oublié j'ai inventé ce
moment je suis désolé coup de froid
coup de froid ici dans le studio pascal
il faut mettre de bulles comme accusera
qui vient aux césars avec sa wii avec
ton forfait d'un dernier coup de blues
coup de blues quand j'ai quitté séverine
[Musique]
dernier coup droit c'était hier
mais elle a un petit garçon maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant d'accueillir mon invité suivante
quelques images rémy de toulouse qui me
dit peux-tu me traiter de con à
l'antenne l'aremiti un convoi là il ya
spéciale dédicace aussi à virginie la
main de maître pour prouver à sa mère la
force d'internet vous voyez madame zana
ça marche
voilà c'est fait olivier qui m'a dit la
fois la plus romantique où j'ai fait
l'amour avec ma fiancée qui s'appelle
dragan à sa copine c'était devant tout
le monde en parle d'un coup ça me fait
plaisir
olivier dragana aussi la famille bourré
c'est patron de la cinq kits en turquie
ils ont un enfant de 9 ans qui s'appelle
maxime ils ont pu l'appeler doigts
jusque là il leur donnait entière
satisfaction
et subitement ce petit maxime a adhéré
au mouvement baptiste donc je te le dit
maxime il ne faut pas être baptiste
maxime je t'invite au gymnase le placent
alors sandrine 32 ans yeux bleus forte
poitrine qui regardent l'émission elle
veut bien le mans saint antoine
c'est pas pour toi elle me dit thierry
je regarde ton émission les seins à
l'air
pourquoi pourquoi parce que j'allaite
des jumeaux
et oui poney
[Applaudissements]
non
et maintenant je dis au revoir à
mathilde seigner qui va les changer
tuvalu s'habiller en fille ces gars là a
dit dans sa aura fait la soirée nord
mathilde on vous adore et on espère bien
que ça me dit vous aurez ce césar ce
césar d'honneur pour l'ensemble de votre
carrière
bien sûr il ya merci d'être venus en
tous les cas et donc il fallait voir la
chambre des magiciennes de claude miller
avec anne brochet mathilde seigner et
puis plein d'autres acteurs que je
citerai à la fin d'émission
merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant voici celles qui violent
fabrice luchini dans barney le film de
bruno chiche
voici marie gillain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais t'as pas être en même temps il
sait faire la fête des jolies filles et
oui c'est sympa ici je joue au foot tu
peux éventuellement ouverture très neige
les deux perles ou ça vous embête qui a
passé un bac pro ça serait mieux
honnêtement ça serait mieux sous métier
entre les deux webcams fernandez avec ce
qui lui fait en ce moment quand même
alors marie gillain on vous a vu dans
mon père ce héros avec depardieu on vous
a vu dans l'appât de bertrand tavernier
dans les affinités électives des frères
taviani dans le bossu de philippe de
broca avec auteuil et luchini dans le
dîner de ettore scola avec vittorio
gassman et c'était 1 à sandrelli et
aujourd'hui on vous voit dans barnie et
ses petites contrariétés de bruno chiche
avec nathalie baye fabrice luchini et
hugo spire voilà alors c'est comment on
fait laurent blanc joue au gymnase
en fait vous êtes vénale baffie non je
ne comprends même pas le mot c'est pour
hbo d1 alors on a déjà parlé de ce film
avec nathalie baye dans la dernière
émission
donc je vais faire le pitch parce que
quand j'aime bien les invités je fais le
pitch n'a pas le pitch à faire lors de
la promo désaxé mais en plus si on est
obligé de faire le pitre alors là donc
c'est feydeau 2001 on pourrait résumer
ce film en lisant ces faits nous 2001
c'est à dire que au trio classique du
vaudeville vous qui êtes maman voilà
vous qui êtes dramaturge maintenant
auteur dramatique je sais qu'en
coulisses en ce moment me prépare un
molière d'honneur et je serai le
recevoir avec dignité
donc effectivement il ya le trio
classique du vaudeville sur le mari la
femme est la maîtresse est ici donc le
mari si luchini la femme c'est nathalie
baye la maîtresse c'est vous évidemment
mais en plus bruno chiche a ajouté un
quatrième personnage dans le trio du
vaudeville
le pitbull en clamant la mort c'est hugo
spire car fabrice luchini dans ce film
est dit est donc toute l'histoire
commence quand il reçoit de sa maîtresse
c'est à dire vous margot de son amant le
même cadeau pour ses 45 ans c'est à dire
un billet sur l'orient-express pour
aller passer un week-end en amoureux à
venise le 1er mai voilà mais comme il
reçoit des deux de son amant et sa
maîtresse il décide de renvoyer les
billets mais il se trompe d'adressé
évidemment c'est un vaudeville ainsi une
comédie donc évidemment ça et alors les
deux amants vous et hugo spire font
connaissance et ils vont à calais pour
rendre visite à barney évidemment où
habite sa femme
voilà donc ces timbres llosa s'appelle
voilà
tu appelles bébé bah oui marc à
l'intérieur lucie et bébé je verrai joue
pas avec soi bien apprendre
tapez avaler cette alliance mavo non
mais ça me fait pas rire magot prends
moi cette alliance non mais je passe de
faire ces petites têtes là hameau situé
à avaler cette alliance je vais être
obligé de te faire avaler un laxatif
surpuissant pour la récupérer avant mon
train de six heures ça sera très
douloureux je pense pas que notre
relation en sortira indemne
je pourrais pas faire autrement plus
grave dans cette alliance rotman je vais
très bien je vais très mal tu m'entends
je vais très très très mal
parmi ces petits quand il était à bercy
avec entre autres marie gillain et notre
invité ce soir
effectivement je dire qu'ils pourraient
résister qua non récurrents qui même
jean moulin aurait craqué absolument
alors votre personnage si une amazone un
peu dominatrice c'est un rôle de
composition on pouvait être comme ça
dans la vraie vie c'est une partie de ma
nature qu'on connaît moins oui mais oui
marc gosset une mangeuse d'hommes elle
et elle joue un peu à la dominatrice
mais au fond c'est une fleur bleue donc
je me retrouve en fait ça très bien
en tous les cas il a la chance de jude
alors on dira pas le nom du jules de
marie tu connais de la savane bien
j'étais même pas au courant pour simone
ferrer voilà donc la nanon le dira pas
que c'est quelqu'un de connu c'est
quelqu'un d'assez connu mais comme cette
émission dans la politique connu pour sa
discrétion aux gars le dire voilà faut
bien dire une des grandes qualités de
cette émission discrétion donc on ne
dira pas on n'en parle pas voilà un
acteur non non un chanteur non
littérature non théâtre non quelqu'un de
bien tout comme très bien tous les codes
non non régir me demande si c'est un ami
en hauteur non ce n'est pas un animateur
non plus mais nécessaire à me faire on
va trouver non ce que je peux dire c'est
pas un indice marie gillain le carré
j'aime les hommes d'expérience dans
sérieux la relation devient plus solide
avec un homme qui a déjà vibrer un
metteur en scène
non voilà un an que tu peux dire poitou
stationné c'est que les cours
d'éducation sexuelle à l'école faisait
rien compris et que finalement vous ai
tout appris par la pratique
voilà c'est comme le cinéma l'écrit
parfaite à l'oral c'était dingue
et alors moi la seule question qui
m'intéresse c'est si un jour vous
découvriez que votre la personne en
question était vite vous réagiriez
comment sérieusement je vous arrivez
vous trouvez au lit avec un mec ça
risquait pas d'arriver mais bon ça
brille on sait jamais hein ben je sais
pas c'est si rare qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire quand c'est une femme
on sent une rivale du même sexe alors
comme ça vous échappe complètement
vous n'êtes pas du tout sur le même
terrain oui voilà or c'est vrai que dans
barney quand margot apprend que son
homme la trompe avec un homme l heure on
peut rien faire c'est callaway ta
puissance et ça bien
j'ai été éduqué dans un milieu très
libérale de toute façon près de liège
dans les années 70 vos parents ils
avaient une ferme il avait retapé une
ancienne ferme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'enfance de marie gillain alors
il faisait pousser des légumes dans le
potager et du fromage de chèvre vous
avez une chèvrerie beau et sexy pour
l'éveil de la sexualité c'est agréable
les légionnaires et alors ils étaient un
peu écolo vos parents un peu un taux
d'ada un ehpad télé chez vous demandera
comment j'ai eu envie de service et oui
c'est vrai j'ai pas de télé vous aviez
rarement au cinéma
regardez la radio c'est un peu je peux
dire la vérité c'est qu'avec une télé
mais au fond de la maison dans une pièce
on se les geler ses 4 degrés dans la
pièce comme ici voilà
sauf que là bas y avait des couvertures
quand même j'avais regardé la télé 1
samedi sur dix a eu des couvertures
comme ça c'est vrai très conviviale très
con petit chef alors évidemment comme
beaucoup d'enfants vous fantasmez sur ce
que vous n'aviez pas évidemment alors le
rêve de marie gillain quand elle était
petite
c'est tout ce qu'on a eue nous
évidemment c'est une chambre bien rangé
un jardinet mignon un petit chien chien
et les tartines dans des tupperware pour
la récré toi c'était son rêve pas du
tout ça elle avait des gros pétards elle
avait des gâteaux shit donc évidemment
ça lui ça lui manquait là c'est vrai je
fantasme né sur la vie en pavillon way
ma meilleure amie habiter dans un
pavillon et car c'est une grande maison
bordélique un peu bohème
entrée 12 août à vocation artistique
d'abord où il est acrobate qui après
dompteuse et il m'a donc deux acrobates
a tous hâte est logique et vos parents
acceptent ils disent bon bah qu'elle
fasse de la danse que ça c'était encore
dans l'impossibilité j'étais obsédé par
le théâtre et dès l'âge de 6 ans vous
faites des petits spectacles dans le
grenier de la maison pour enfants dire
votre mère votre mère écrivait des
contes pour enfants est sûr c'est que je
raconte votre vie exactement c'est un
conte votre vie voilà la maman de marie
faisait le mercredi après midi l'atelier
pomme il est tous les enfants du village
qui fait c'est vrai il ya il
tous ensemble et et majorettes je sais
pas ça non mais c'était mon fantasme
ah bon non mais c'est vrai c'était comme
le pavillon j'ai eu un choc violent
majorettes je voulais majorettes ça me
faisait fantasmer les petites bottes
blanches en cuir les petites oreilles
parce que nous on n'a pas triché youri
ici qui qui est très branché majorettes
je sais pas si vous êtes branché patrick
fiori en même temps j'aime bien les
majorettes de prendre un joker
oui c'est marrant qui répond quand on
prend un joker c'est laurent qui répond
donc c'est pas mieux là bien alors à 14
ans vous entrez dans un cours de théâtre
le vivier à liège
et alors vous faites un premier casting
à 14 ans premier casting pour l'amant et
vos parents vous laissez les faire le
casting de la mort mon père m'accompagne
commun quand même oui oui il est bien
beau mais je veux dire j'avais 13 ans et
demi je me suis amené en salopette en
jean
heureusement heureusement marie gillain
est refusé heureusement des ions la
directrice de casting garde le nom de
marie sa photo et un an après l'appel
pour mon père ce héros de gérard lauzier
avec depardieu voilà quoi cette chaîne
carrière alors le casting c'est
l'horreur on arrive déjà morte de trac
intimider et donc je me rappelle j'avais
eu à peu près 5 5 à 7 minutes dans les
tenants et toilettes pour répéter mon
texte je pensais que j'allais peut-être
avoir un acteur qu il m 2 mais la
réplique pas du tout c'était la
directrice de casting du reste très très
bien et qui me donnait la réplique dans
un bureau voilà assis sur une chaise et
puis moi j'avais un carton avec mon nom
écrit au feutre que je devais baisser
mon carton sert le plus joli sourire et
puis commencer ma scène on passait par
là et que vous êtes sortis ou pensez
vous aviez été nulle en vérité je
m'étais senti vraiment lamentable mais
vraiment j'avais honte
ils ont rappelé le lendemain oui ça a
été assez vite alors vous avez fait le
premier film donc c'est avec depardieu
quand même s'est passé comment avec
depardieu donc vous deviez être super
intimider quand même là bizarrement non
un bon mon père la télé numérique moi
j'ai trop jeune pour être intimidé en
fait c'est à dire que la première fois
il m'a balancé une grosse blague bien
dégueulasse ça détend du las manos qui
n'ont comme quoi ça détend l'atmosphère
c'était quoi vous en souvenez non j non
je me rappelle qu'un truc bien non par
contre j'ai un souvenir du tournage avec
beaucoup voilà justement c'est ça en
tournée dans une boîte on trouvait dans
une boîte de nuit où la journée à l'île
maurice est alors évidemment à l'île
maurice il ya beaucoup de blancs
coloniaux un peu pro de foot et à ce
sujet justement on devait danser un slow
et je crois que gérard avait vraiment
rien repas bien arrosé et et alors il a
commencé à faire des gaz et il est parti
dans un fou rire extraordinaire et je
l'entends encore dire gaz le slogan est
tous les blancs claudio que tu es là où
vous [ __ ]
[Musique]
bien c'est chose cette émission ouais
bien alors on va faire une table
première fois
[Musique]
pour la bouche pendant le dîner coeur
un nouvel avis
qui est mien vient de répondre avec
l'accent belge de liège des plus beaux
jeux les plus originaux voire faire
l'interview première fois mais avec
l'accent non non non oui vraiment vous
le fait vachement bien
j'ai par exemple vient d'autoriser des
belges qui regarde à voile et à tous les
liégeois je vous embrasse très voilà
c'est bien on avait julie snyder normal
ça fait déborder une bonne analyse c'est
exactement ce que je pense des
québécoises mois bonsoir de gilles
ménage qui est là bonsoir
alors votre premier souvenir mon premier
souvenir avec l'accent est à dire avec
l'accent oui premier souvient mon
premier souvenir
le sourire de ma mère
non là je peux pas dire ça mais pas
comme ça
pourquoi accents d'un sourire de ma mère
c'est beaucoup mieux déjà premier choc
de votre vie moi quand j'ai appris que
le père noël n'existait pas on peut pas
dire comme moi quand j'ai appris que le
père noël n'existait pas j'ai été
vraiment choqués voilà bah oui mais ça
fera du tout le monde sur l'accord jolie
fille comme ça et ça tu sais je sais
pourquoi j'ai beaucoup je fais ça pour
pas être amoureux bon maintenant je vous
libère de l'accent belge parce qu'on
rentre dans des questions compliquées
donc je ne veux pas que vous soyez bien
perturbé prend l'accent sionisme
premiers amours premières amours martin
il s'appelait martin était plus âgée que
vous non même âge même âge quel âge à
quel âge c'était 16 ans à 16 ans datant
du 16 ans oui c'était très prude un
trait aux minguettes à quel âge luis
régis boissié danger grave aussi je
connais la suivante tu vas la pause et
alors premier visé exactement fernandez
il pourrait la faire à ma place cette
émission
premier baiser premier baiser c'était
dans la cour de l'école en fait je
fantasmais sur un type et je crois que
je l'échoppé il était en short
c'était un cours de gym un et je sais
pas pourquoi je me suis avancé vers lui
et je l'embrassé sur la bouche et ça a
été assez magique
ouais voilà c'est exactement comme avec
le cnid en barney finalement vous êtes
pas beaucoup changé ça c'était sans la
langue ou avec la langue ça
enregistrement des premiers baisers avec
la langue
c'était moins bien ah bon pourquoi ça
vous dégoûter la langue non mais je m'en
étais fait tout un monde enfin mais en
fait non ah non
avant c'était qui hervé benhaddou il
s'appelait au nom les géniaux bon
premier flirt poussé flirt poussé ben
c'était c'était à 17 ans dans une cabane
dans la crau la la la la la première
fois pour de vrai ah d'accord ça c'est
non le flirt poussé parce que j'entends
je pas commencé en belgique mais ce que
j'entends d'un flirt poussé on fait
beaucoup de choses mais on ne fait pas
la chose moi je me rappelle que de là
vraiment la bagarre a mis d'acord
c'était là la creuse où manger quoi on
mangeait des miel pops
ça vous a marqué à la madeleine à voir
sa première fois à trois et vous mets
toi c'était à troyes dans l'aube donc
moi j'étais bien trop longtemps
problème c'est que c'était avec mon
meilleur ami donc c'était et sa fiancée
et ses parents sinon laurent non
bonjour dirai pas plus bon d'accord
première fois à 4 ah ça non
premier chagrin d'amour à combien là
parce que j'ai du mal à suivre
premier chagrin d'amour la première fois
où je devais avoir 20 ans j'étais
amoureuse d'un funambule qui m'a laissé
tomber comme une vieille chaussette ou
pour travailler proportionnelle il est
hongre première cuite première cuite
c'était je crois en pologne sous comme
un polonais on dit toujours des
vêtements pologne sont jamais mis trop
de vodka ont tourné dans les tatras
mais c'est dans un hôtel qui ressemble à
une plage à celui de shining voilà donc
on se console est temps qu'on pouvait
dans la vodka première cigarette au
cabanis je viens toujours thierry j'aime
pas comment vous émission vous poser la
question sur le cabanis d'accord hervé
première cigarette au cabanis n'y a pas
très longtemps c'était à la jamaïque
avait marqué vous vous bourrez en
pologne
vous fumez vous fumez vers la jamaïque
vous êtes
quelque chose au bon endroit vous les
révéler mais c'est bien première chose
que vous faites le matin en vous
réveillant je me rende à la très bonne
réponse
dernière chose que vous faites le soir
avant de vous coucher je me passe de la
crème sur les pieds sur les pieds non
mais moi
et avant de vous endormir dernière chose
que vous faites c'est quoi avant de vous
coucher vous mettez de la crème dans les
pieds d'erding de bouchons de la crème
avant de vous endormir
non je parle pas de trucs de sexe vous
pouvez faire une prière vous pouvez
faire votre examen de conscience
voilà vous avez mercer qui on vous dit
ça
marie gillain
fabrice luchini et
avant barney
ces petites contrariétés de bruno chiche
voilà merci beaucoup
avant la guerre ont invité suivant
quelques emails alors oui voilà ça c'est
une question importante beaucoup
d'e-mails de l'étranger pourquoi tv5
diffuse du monde en parle avec plusieurs
semaines de retard mais c'est un mystère
on sait rien moi pourquoi france 2 ne
rediffuse pas tout le monde en parle
pareil mystère je ne sais pas je sais ça
bien imed le melbourne
we do not move du ring de dingle e-mails
le plus extraordinaire c'est un email de
bernard et michel qui sont à langue fang
à 35 km de pékin et qui voit les
missions avec cinq semaines de retard
bien entendu dont bernard michel je vous
salue vraiment
[Musique]
et
alors changement de tripes maintenant
celui que j'accueille a longtemps été
l'homme le plus puissant de france
mesdames messieurs et oui voici gilles
ménage
[Musique]
gilles ménage bonsoir je vais vous
présenter parce que comment vous avez
passez votre temps à vouloir 10 crèches
obligé de raconter un peu qui vous êtes
parce que gilles ménage c'est pas un nom
qui dit grand chose en dehors des
cercles politiques et des cercles du
pouvoir
alors vous êtes né en 1943 à
bourg-la-reine et fait l'ena mais de
sortie de l'ena en 69
vous avez été chef de cabinet d'un
secrétaire d'état aux postes et
télécommunications qui s'appelait pierre
lelong entre 74 et 75 de 77 à 80 vous
êtes directeur de cabinet d'un certain
nombre de préfets voilà c'est tout ce
qu'on sait sur vous vous êtes une
discrétion absolue autant marie gillain
je connais pratiquement la marque du
téléviseur de ses parents faudel je
connais tout sur sa grand mère vous avez
été d'une discrétion exemplaire sur
votre parcours avant la politique et le
pouvoir alors sur votre enfance
en ce qui est assez étonnant c'est que
vous avez été quelqu'un qui a fait
écouter pas mal de gens à paris à
l'époque vous étiez à l'elysée mais vous
vous protéger jalousement votre vie
privée ou le qu'on parle de ça non on
parlera de ça mais ce que je veux dire
c'est par exemple aussi moi je me pose
des questions très simples aux parents
et c'est quoi tout simplement
moi j'ai perdu mon père très jeune n'ont
pas connu j'ai été le dernier d'une
famille nombreuse de cet enfant donc ma
mère a dû travailler pour élever leurs
familles donc j'ai vécu une enfance
normale
j'ai fait des études comme tout le monde
et puis voilà on n'a rien trouvé
10h un peu un peu vénère parce qu'on a
rien de trouvé alors quand on trouve un
alors premier baiser
alors 80 vous rentrez quand mitterrand
est élu vous rentrez à l'elysée en juin
qui lui en mai vont rentrer en juin
aidée par andré rousselet
à l'époque d'abord vous êtes conseiller
technique et puis vous êtes directeur
adjoint du cabinet de françois
mitterrand et en 82 vous devenez
l'artisan de ce qu'on a appelé la
cellule antiterroriste mise en place
après l'attentât de la rue des rosiers
alors c'est une cellule à cellule
antiterroriste le responsable le
commandant prouteau qui était l'ancien
patron du gign et là les affaires de
police vont devenir un des domaines
réservés de la présidence et votre
sobriquet
c'était le troisième ministre de
l'intérieur puisque avait un vrai
ministre de l'intérieur il y avait jean
de berry joue aussi mal à l époque vous
êtes en liaison constante avec le
ministre d'intérieur la dgse la dst la
présidence les archers une section
d'ailleurs spécialisée dans l'espionnage
des hommes politiques
alors thierry pfister qui était
longtemps à matignon avec mauroy qui
maintenant est dans l'édition dit de
vous gilles ménage entrée à l'elysée
pour y exercer son patronyme
c'est bien c'est bien dit et en 88 quand
mitterrand est réélu vous de venir là
réellement directeur de cabinet voilà
aujourd'hui vous publier le troisième et
dernier volume dans une série qui
s'appelle l'oeil du pouvoir zoom zoom
mon garçon sait comment fait gilles avec
les mains attention
oh
j'ai bien joué j'ai mal
voilà vous
il a eu du pouvoir face au terrorisme
moyen-orientale 1981 1986 et c'est donc
le troisième tome de votre récit de
l'époque voilà vous parlez du terrorisme
moyen-orientale c'est quelque chose qui
à l'air loin comme ça parce que c'était
les années 80 sauf que on voit bien
aujourd'hui on a appris il ya pas
longtemps quéven l'attentât qui était
prévu à strasbourg des attentats prévus
à paris donc on voit bien qu'on est
toujours quand même là dedans et que ça
suspendue au dessus de nos têtes un peu
comme une épée de damoclès
alors les raisons de cette période
d'attentats c'était quoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'à l'époque il ya eu tous ces
attentats qui ont été perpétrés contre
des intérêts français
je suis un peu désolé d'être un peu
professoral dans une salle noire faisait
son charme c'est de passer comme ça de
la légèreté à la gravité le problème le
premier problème et laisse problèmes
essentiels c'était le problème
palestinien
c'est à dire cette lutte de qui était
qu'on avait du reste pas très bien
analysé qui opposait les deux hits i
missed qui s'est incliné arafat qui
voulait donc une solution négociée et le
jusqu'au boutiste les groupes abou nidal
et hérat qui s'opposèrent arafat et on a
pensé on avait englober tous ces deux
tendances sous le terme générique de
palestiniens alors qu ils s'affrontaient
et la nouveauté de l'année 1980 c'est
qu'au lieu d'avoir simplement les
règlements de comptes entre eux si vous
voulez les pays occidentaux notamment la
france parce qu'il commence à soutenir
arafat dans son effort de paix devienne
cible voilà donc on passe si vous dans
ce qui se passe donc c'est quand 80 le
sommet de venise la france choisit de
soutenir l'ol paie comme interlocuteur
pour israël et tout donc tous les
palestiniens qui sont anti olp comme
abou nidal effectivement commencé à
déclencher les attentats donc qu'est la
rue copernic dont on se souvient dont la
rue des merciers la rue copernic
l'analyse par exemple de françois
mitterrand de copernic est totalement
erronée ils seront complètement de se
tromper tout le monde se trompe parce
qu'on a accusé l'extrême droite au
départ tout le monde se trompe
et alors le deuxième facteur qui va qui
va accélérer cette cette donnée c'est la
situation au liban qui détériorent à
partir de 82 à la suite de l'invasion
israélienne et le troisième facteur
c'est la guerre entre l'irak et oui
alors sur le je vous arrête parce que
sur le liban il ya l'image
le drakkar à beyrouth qui a été détruit
il ya eu aussi la sphère du dc 10 d'uta
dont on parle bien plus tard en fait en
sort un bouquin en ce moment qui en
parle le dc10 qui a été détruit au
dessus du ténéré il le détournement
c'est beaucoup d'attentes à l'époque
quand on se souvient le détournement de
l'airbus alger marseille et c'est là que
le gign est intervenu sur l'aéroport
pour libérer les otages
puis les fameuses otages français au
liban dont on voyait les noms tous les
soirs au journal télévisé de france 2
marcel fontaine marcel carton jean paul
kauffmann et michel seurat qui est mort
après une agonie
après une agonie kerry alors ce qui est
intéressant de savoir aujourd'hui on
vous ayant vous c'est face à ça en tout
cas comme ça une espèce de profusion
d'attentât et d'actes criminels
perpétrés contre un pays
comment réagit gouvernement comment
réagit gouvernement de la france parce
qu'il est un peu impuissant un peu
démuni face à ça non à la fois bien et
mal
c'est à dire que je pense que les
critiques qui ont été faites à l'époque
n'était pas n'était pas justifiée par
exemple la critique de faiblesse n'est
pas justifiée n'était pas fondée en
revanche je pense que si on s'est trompé
et on s'est trompé je crois qu'il faut
dire qu'on s'est trompé on s'est trompé
sur quoi j'ai mena on s'est trompé
on a mal analysé la situation c'est à
dire par exemple on a mal compris quels
étaient les mécanismes de fonctionnement
interne du régime iranien qu'on a
d'abord un petit peu considérée comme
une révolution à la française puis après
il n'a perçu que c'était un petit peu
différent on a je pense vous estimé
qu'elle était la difficulté d'être
présents au liban
on avait comme disent les anglais une
intelligente c'est à dire une
connaissance en matière de renseignement
qui était quasiment nul et je trouve
qu'il ya peser gravement dans la gestion
la sphère des otages à dire que par
exemple on n'a jamais su pendant en tout
cas la période que je traite ou 10 était
et il y avait des rapports qui disait
que c'était séparés lors qu'on fait a
perçu une fois qu'ils sont libérés
qu'ils étaient toujours ensemble
les services de renseignement français
étaient incapables de dire où et n'était
pas n était pas meilleure les anglais
n'en parlons pas de la deuxième
faiblesse c'est que je pense qu'on a eu
on n'a pas été assez unis aussi bien sur
la scène intérieure que sur la scène
internationale entre les pays concernés
si par exemple les américains les
français et les anglais qui était de 3
principales puissances concernées par
ces preneurs d otages avaient uni leurs
efforts ou une chapka mener sa petite
son petit business dans son coin on s'en
serait mieux sorti et la troisième la
troisième chose c'est que finalement ce
qui est terrible c'est taper le
terrorisme c'est que comme usé comme le
terrorisme était en fait manipuler par
les états finalement ces états ne sont
pas si mal tirée cnis bah oui et et la
logique si vous voulez de la relation de
l'état à l'état l'a emporté finalement
sur la terreur face à françois
mitterrand une attitude assez ferme il
dit tout faire sauf cd on a souvent
présenté la faire comme étant si vous
voulez une sorte de d'équilibré à avoir
entre la protection des citoyens et la
raison de l'état ou des états et en fait
c'était un petit peu mal posé le
problème parce que s'ils ont cédé en
favorisant la protection de l'individu
on ne savait pas dans quel engrenage on
mettait la main donc finalement c'était
aussi une façon de protéger les futurs
éventuels d'otages que de nous passer
des compliqué la politique française a
été plutôt plutôt efficace alors on
apprend plein de trucs dans votre livre
à on apprend par exemple que quand il ya
eu quand l'immeuble du drakkar a été
détruit il ya une tentative de
représailles du gouvernement français
une jeep bourré d'explosifs qui a été
mise devant l'ambassade d'iran à
beyrouth
mais le dispositif de mise à feu n'a pas
fonctionné on savait pas ce truc on
apprend en lisant votre bouquin
qu'ensuite on a essayé de faire sauter
la jeep avec un bazooka
ça n'a pas marché non plus et quand même
ce qui prouve que les mecs sont pas
quand même très fort et nouvel échec
donc il a dit pas été récupéré et
effectivement ils savaient très bien
qu'ils avaient 1007 gip et donc la
france est devenue à ce moment-là
l'ennemi
juré des mollahs on apprend aussi que la
france à l'époque a vendu des super
étendard à l'irak ce qui fait qu
évidemment ça nous a mis les iraniens
encore plus sur le dos je crois qu'il a
mieux valu que cette jeep n'explose pas
ouais parce que il faut savoir par
exemple que les américains ont fait la
même chose vraiment plus tard en 1985 le
glissement 8 mars 85 ils ont fait
exploser une véhicule près de la
résidence du cheikh fadlallah qu'était
un des responsables du hezbollah
libanais et celle là elle a explosé
ouais 880 morts et ça a été l'origine
l'origine de la prise d'otages ça a été
ça voilà ce qui va partir de ce moment
là le hezbollah s'est mis à faire la
chasse aux espions et les français qui
ont été pris
c'est à dire d'abord gilles pérol est
ensuite marseille car pour marcel
fontaine c'est suite à ça exactement
voilà donc ça s'appelle l'oeil du
pouvoir de gilles ménage alors à parler
d'une autre affaire maintenant
[Musique]
allez
raccrocher c'est une horreur les écoutes
à ça c'était le premier tome ce assez
d'argent et le troisième dans le premier
tome vous en parler on pas raconter
toute la sphère des écoutes mais enfin
en tant que responsable de cette cellule
étaient au centre du système alors ce
qu'on peut dire pour aller vite c'est
qu'à l'époque donc l'elysée a fait
écouter un journaliste du monde
s'appelle edwy plenel suite à l affaire
des irlandais de vincennes carole
bouquet paul barril jean-edern hallier
madame fabius françoise castro et ils
ont pas toujours été écoutés pour des
raisons d'intérêt national moi je n'ai
jamais nié que sa société existait au
début vous avez unis et à au début vous
êtes réfugier derrière le secret défense
non c'est pas j'ai à l'époque mystère de
mise l'intérieur figurez-vous était
monsieur charles pasqua ouais et donc je
reçois une convocation chez le jeu je me
doutais bien que j'allais être interrogé
sur cette question je téléphone à
monsieur pasqua je lui dis monsieur le
ministre
qu'est ce que je fais parce que
normalement c'est un phénomène n'a été
couvert par le secret défense
est-ce que je doit opposer le secret
défense il nous dit oui oui c'est ce que
vous devez faire je dis vous êtes bien
sûr
à matignon on est bien d'accord oui
téléphonez à monsieur nicolas bazire je
téléphone nicolas bazire je ne prends
les instructions comme tout
fonctionnaire doit prendre ses
instructions aux terres et donc je suis
arrivé devant le juge lui dit secret
défense c'est bien ce que je dis voilà
donc je n'ai pas répondu d'accord je
n'ai pas nier sinon mais après il ya eu
deux bouquins gilles ménage qui
s'appelait les oreilles du président de
porto et du puits et guerre secrète l
elysée de barils ce qui fait qu'en 96
dans le point vous finissez quand même
par dire bah oui vous dit même que les
ordres venaient de mitterrand il ya un
moment où vous êtes bien obligé d'avouer
qu'il ya eu des écoutes à l'elysée quand
même je me signale que si si vous violez
secret défense est aussi passible de
sept ans d'emprisonnement
ah bon c'est s'étant alors faut quand
même fallu sept ans et je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas répondu je n'ai pas levé le
secret défense pour une raison qui est
une raison juridique c'est que se poser
un problème de savoir si les faits
étaient prescrits ou pas et lorsque la
cour de cassation a fait un revirement
jurisprudentiel en disant qu'il n'y
avait pas prescription
à ce moment là ça devenait intenable et
contre l'avis des premiers ministres de
l'époque a été monsieur juppé
j'ai décidé il s'affranchir du bien
alors pour en venir à ces écoutes quand
même bon quand on écoute jean edern
hallier
on comprend j'ai un dernier s'apprête à
publier dans son journal l'idiot
international
en feuilletant le contenu d'un livre qui
s'appelle l'honneur perdu de françois
mitterrand qui parle de sa fille secrète
mazarine et d'autres choses bon là on
comprend on apprend même dire que tous
les jeunes que c'est dumas ont démarché
des imprimeurs pour bloquer l'idiot
international à ce moment là donc ça on
peut comprendre dit pas que c'est bien
enfin on peut comprendre car le bouquet
par exemple ce combat honnêtement je ne
sais pas et jésus si focus balaj dit
lâche à la question pourquoi mitterrand
ou alors il était amoureux d'elle
un james bond a déconné ramifications
internationales en sais rien la seule
explication elle la donne parce qu'il a
été entendu
elle a été entendue par le juge
d'instruction et l'indiqué il a expliqué
qu'à l'époque pas du tout entrer dans sa
vie prime et enfin le livre quelqu'un
etc
bon bref et que cette personne si vous
voulez cet été elle qui était surveillé
bon alors vous avez dit je ne crois pas
que dans une autre démocratie on eût agi
autrement face à une telle situation
peut-être est-ce que vous pensez c'est
important ça vous pensez qu'à un moment
la raison d'état dans une démocratie
comme la france qui se targue en plus
d'être un modèle de démocratie
vous pensez que c'est normal qu'on
écoute les lignes téléphoniques des gens
non ce que je dis c'est que ce faire
donc est ce qui s'est passé dans
l'affairé des écoutes de l'élysée
puisque c'est comme ça qu'on appelle qui
un jour ce sera jugé bon ça sera jugé
vingt ans après les faits le livre un
bon c'est comme ça c'est le système
judiciaire français
il se trouve que à un moment donné on y
raisons qui ne sont pas des raisons
neutre qui sont des raisons de basses
manoeuvres politiques et autres on a
levé une partie du couvercle moi je dis
sur vingt lignes d'un bien sûr peu près
de 1000 lignes qui sont utilisés par le
gouvernement
si à la même époque on avait élevé 20
autres lignes le couvert sur votre livre
on aurait découvert à peu près la même
chose si on le faisait aujourd'hui on
découvrira peut pas la même j'ai souvent
dit attendez c'est important cirque
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui gilles ménage on est nous
enfin nous les citoyens français peuvent
être écoutées par le gouvernement il ya
une loi la différence et qu'entre le la
situation de l'époque et la situation de
maintenance et qu'il ya une loi on s'est
un peu plus réglementée sur le fond des
choses ce n'est pas parce que quand on
est quand c'est des jardins sont des
trafiquants de drogue on peut comprendre
quand c'est le genre qui sont des
criminels des trafiquants mais quand on
fait écouter jean edern hallier une
planque derrière la raison d'état maison
des tas de raisons pour éviter les à
l'envi le savez l'état fait des
conneries 1
dans une démocratie c'est quand même
grave ça qu'on va pas battre ma coulpe
sur la fonction de l'état oui j'étais
quand même pas prendre tout ça vous
regarde pas trop non j'étais pas le
patron tout ça lorsque lorsqu'il y avait
ce système a été mis en place il était
mis en place avec l'agrément du
au moment de mon époque aider le
gouvernement ne s'y pierre mauroy et
l'agrément successeur quitté monsieur
famille et ce qui me choque dans 6 et
passe actuellement c'est que tout le
monde ait oublié
il y avait il y avait 400 gr la gaieté
avec des câbles dans les enfants les
cav's et qui bidouille est tout seul
c'est pas vrai il y avait des procédures
qui étaient suivies il y avait un
décision la responsabilité elle était
ministériels et les responsables aussi
des communistes à moi ce que je demande
on peut discuter du bien fondé ou du mal
fondé oui mais qu' on ne reporte pas si
j'ose dire la culpabilité sur quelques
façons lamizana l'itc mitterrand
puisqu'on a retrouvé des écoutes a noté
par mitterrand dans la marge donc
aujourd'hui que mais tellement adoré ça
mais ça existait avant et ça existe
toujours maintenant oui non peut-être
que lui il a utilisé d'une façon plus
personnelle savais j'aurais beaucoup de
pas dire sur la façon dont on utilise ce
système et je crois que dans les
démocraties qui se targue d'être verra
on utilise ce système en france et
actuellement je dirais même que c'est de
pire en pire en pire en pire pas à cause
d'une déréglementation ou comment
dirais-je d'un usage qui serait
déraisonnable mais simplement parce que
la technique
oui c'est tellement développé maintenant
pas écouté les portables tout écouter
mais faut bien alors je vous pose est
maintenant une dernière question est-ce
que vous éteignez la lumière
[Musique]
question simple gilles ménage question
très simple vous êtes un service de
l'état faisait fed et n'avait été dans
les cabinets préfectoraux est ce que
finalement maintenant avec le recul
puisque vous publier des livres pour en
parler
est ce que vous regrettez pas excuse est
pas un peu honte d'avoir fait tout ça
avait même en nombre je pense déjà envie
non je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
d'abord je les qualifie pas comme vous
les qualifiés est ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'une décision a
été prise
j'ai toujours fait un papier écrit j'ai
toujours demandé d instruction je suis
instructions je ne pense vraiment pas
avoir franchi la ligne jaune
enfin on ne veut pas je veux pas vous
chargez m'enfin papon aussi dit moi je
ne faisait qu'obéir aux ordres
quand on est fonctionnaire au départ
mais quand on est fonctionnaire on peut
le dire j'ai obéi aux ordres il veut
bien non jours que des fois il faut
savoir désobéir
c'est ce que tout le monde a dit à
papandréou non vous auriez dû désobéi on
n'était pas du tout dans cette
configuration là je vous n'avez pas la
situation était moins grave
bon lorsque ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est le fond de ma réponse un
fonctionnaire si vous voulez ne peut pas
prendre l'initiative en tout cas moi
c'est ma philosophie
sans être totalement en harmonie avec le
pouvoir politique
or il se trouve que dans son pays dans
ce pays à taden politique parce que ça
les arrange parce qu'ils ont des soucis
de carrière sont parfois amnésique
parfois renégats et ça devient un peu
facile de dire ben voilà
on n'était pas au courant on savait pas
de taper le lampiste alors vous dites
non moi je pas après tout je trouve que
j'ai eu beaucoup de satisfactions à
faire ce métier il ya depuis quelques
années c'est vrai beaucoup
d'inconvénients
je pense que dans la vie il faut savoir
accepter les inconvénients c'est
davantage bien même merci je me regarde
je me regarde film hélas merci luis je
vous salue vous y allez merci
bon bah on vous souhaite tout ce qu'on
peut
[Applaudissements]
vivant pile
[Musique]
ahmed sheikh chanter mère ne fallait
plus que je chantais géré chanter désolé
j'ai encore avoir plein dimanche
j'accueille maintenant petit off
[Applaudissements]
safari
tiens
[Applaudissements]
ah ben je vais dire bonsoir tout le
monde aime bien titoff bien et attend sa
toile
sexe
titin bon titoff alors à faire on va
faire une promo à moi je fais pas moi
c'est mon choix
les empêche pas au gymnase moi je picore
alors trop beau à mort la scène c'est
par mois c'est parce que c'était je
crois que c'était mon père n'était pas
mon père qu'est ce que c'est
je sais pas c'était c'est le père de ma
fille ah oui à six voix la sienne oui
comment ça va la scène c'est fabuleux
bah oui ça se passe très bien on est à
partir du 1er mars attacks jungle à
tourner et j'ai fait le palais des
congrès à marseille deux soirs pour
lancer la tournée un peu par
superstition et là je suis
je vais marcher bien là oui ça a
cartonné à paris donc on débouche sur la
tournée voila voila il fait partie et
c'est celui qui m'a donné le titre du
mec le plus mauvais en promo j'accepte
tout à fait ça m'a quand même bien le
cinéma sont nés ou le cinéma parce qu'on
vous avez vu dans comme un aimant ouais
et alors
et là il ya j'ai joué dans les jolies
choses qui va sortir à la rentrée s'il
est d'origine et des dépenses voilà
aussi un petit rôle j'ai un petit
passage et c'est bien comme un aimant
ouais tu trouves
non sérieusement c'était bien beau but
j'ai eu un plaisir fou à la faire
plaisir vous succomberez faut dire ça
oui c'est j'ai eu un plaisir fou à
tourner ce film c'est bien faut le dire
ça c'est bien mais faut le garder ça
vient et filles ça va comment ça va très
bien c'est un peu dans les plages et des
infos ça va moins ça va mieux que bien
dit je les connais le clip
non disons que là je me suis à la
rigueur j'étais peut-être plus acharnés
à 20,15 de 15 à 25 ans maintenant ah bon
c'est bizarre hein ah oui c'est bizarre
ça vous laisse un peu la whey mais il
faut pas trop dévoiler donc il vaut
mieux masquer surjoue un peu que ouais
vous laisse y joue pas seulement le mien
qu'il habite à la main sans arrêt
[Musique]
évidemment non
tard
what it off alors on va pouvoir on va
vous voir sur scène là attention
magnéto serge ça c'est beau après
général il passa une gros plan général
ya une chasseur ou un pêcheur qui arrive
souvent et chasseurs bayer et bien filmé
en groupe à bâtir la moitié nord et lui
il arrive en plein de news à peu près un
modèle arrivera bien un grand gardien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais un pompier
ses premiers mots qu'il est inconscient
maintien du bullet with you
ça vaut bien ça s'est passé couché pas
obligés de bosser que gdrive matin non
pas dans la boîte donc pas le bâton
chercheurs va t'en as pas bougé aussi
touché la banque ils apple arrive à
boucher le postier dans la boîte grand
bal dans la bataille à papa qui
comprennent tout moi ce sont mes amis
résider sur la vie moi j'ai eu mon mur
car bien changé
il a découvert par c'est un petit
chauffeur a pris comme ça côté la
cohabitation aulas le petit chevron a
pris les magnifiques qu'il bouderait pas
me dit voilà c'est magnifique qu'est ce
que c'est beau j'adore à un tuyau qu'est
ce que c'est magnifique
si on arrive à s'approcher de
l'explosive nous à parfaire le cri sont
en phase iib famille je ne comprends pas
j'ai pas mal aussi
oui ma mini dv settama lacombe tout à
fait une saint louis
marc meyer vote mais qu'est ce que tu
vois ce moment là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sauf nouveau phénomène s'est vraiment
bien merci
ah ouais nan bon c'est génial moi
j'adore jeterai clients depuis le début
et là il faut aller le voir la tournée
des communes d'ath ces normes
il ya beaucoup date ouais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de dates est terminée non
j'étais alors j'avoue champions dormi là
oui c'est normal il ya vraiment beaucoup
d'attelage attaque ainsi le premier
maintenant on va faire une interview psy
titoff est égal on ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle
c'est l'interview psy ci est ce que vous
êtes mytho non non mythomane non j'aime
bien dans le spectacle il ya beaucoup de
personnages qui sont complètement mytho
mais moi dans la vie je suis pas je suis
pas spécialement me thonon non et je
détecte souvent les les mythomanes
j'adore ça quand il ya quelqu'un qui
arrive commence à parler que sa part il
commence à raconter n'importe quoi ça
c'est fabuleux 1
sais-tu détecte là où d'ailleurs je vous
écoute et il croit elle lui raconte
qu'il est ce que vous êtes
skeezo zizou zizou je suis skizomeuh
ouais ouais ouais ben obligatoirement
quand
consommation quand on va sur scène mais
c'est pas non plus très très loin de ce
que je suis dans la vie parano parano
complètement complètement croyais que
tout le monde vous déteste du mal de
vous non non mais je suis parano qua non
mais pas non non c'est pas ça dd non
c'est pas ça par le passé avec son frère
avec son frère et son copain oh [ __ ]
peu parano c'est ça ça donne un exemple
si tout le monde déteste je ne fais pas
la paranoïa par rapport à par rapport à
ça par exemple mais pas pour plein de
trucs je fais s'il ya un bruit ou je
fais je bloque vite sur ça c'est la
mauvaise herbe
la parano ça voilà viens je suis pas
parano je fais le tour de dakhla si
c'est pas parano c'est trop de jus il ya
deux choses qui arrivent
j'aime parc pendant vos émissions vous
posez la question sourire quelques
années bien maso non vous n'aimez pas
les saintes
ça c'est bon c'est bon c'est pas j'aime
bien les ça j'aime bien timé papa
jusqu'à la douleur a notamment justin
cinq ans ça donne des petits frissons
il est sympa c'est dommage qu'il regarde
tu as l fille
[Rires]
bien est-ce que vous êtes sado ça
donnera non tu vas pas faire mal non une
petite fessée de temps en temps il va
générer la petite fessée cantal ont bien
mérité le titre et c'est là je te
regarde encore une fois mais oui oui là
n'était pas obligé de la prochaine
question ce n'est pas obligée de
regarder mais est-ce que vous êtes seaux
d'eau titeuf enfin franchement oui
bailly si on répond franchement tout le
temps mais moi je réponds tout temps
franchement dans la vie je suis pas un
passionné
avant je n'en sais pas non non c'est
wayne dans un des fois quand
pour donner un petit peu de piquant
c'est à dire c'est un peu comme les
aventuriers par l'ancien je suis pas
allé dans ce pays
et oui vous êtes sur france 2 chef du
service que les messieurs je vous êtes
exhibo bizarrement je suis assez chasse
est réservé et c'est par exemple j'aime
pas téléphoner devant des gens certains
trucs mais par contre c'est vrai que
faire faire l'amour dans d'autres
personnes
ouais ça peut être sympa d'en payer
il ya du bon ben là il ya 2 3 millions
de gens est-ce que vous êtes homo ah non
je vous êtes trio oui la première fois à
la barre que moi ben voilà mes parents
regardent ça bien jouer et de montrer
vers me dit l'heure d'aller chercher une
bière dans le frigo
ouais ouais est ce que vous êtes fétiche
au nom pas porno pour garder des
cassettes ça m'a passé ça chauffe ça
ridicule mais c'est vers 12 13 ans vous
avez votre époque
ouais bah c'était les débuts par contrat
est ce que vous êtes géronto géronto
c'est quand on se tape des gens plus
vieux à
ah non non une fille de 32 ans mais bon
ouais voilà non jusqu'à 40h pas d'accord
parce que jusqu'à 50 60 est ce que vous
êtes zoo moi je sais pas tant des
sénateurs groupe six mois oui oui mais
ces interviews qu surtout ya un mec qui
m'a envoyé un email non mais dis non non
il ya un mec qui m'ont envoyé un e-mail
pourquoi tu te demande pas aux invités
quand tu fais une interview psy vous
avez de la chance c'est pas tomber sur
vous on vous a vu et toi non plus est ce
que vous êtes nécro à l'aï laissé non
scato et des fois ça on n'est pas
uniquement maintenant jusqu'à tôt par
exemple la salle aussi n'ont pas discuté
et est ce que vous êtes adamo non adamo
qu'est ce que tu attends parade
amoureuse qu'on est madame okayama
d'amour oui oui alors je refuse dire que
de mettre à dos d'âne à bord voilà comme
c'est écrit sur le maintien
à la question est ce que vous êtes adamo
pendant l'acte sexuel c'est obligatoire
une fois d'amour village arrive pas
[Musique]
et oui la pie qui est le mien
après marie gillain encore une belle
joie si christine okrent appel à mes
yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir terrière du pauvre vous
arrivez après cette interview je pense
que je me suis dit jusque ménages s'est
dit aussi elle peut pas bouton métier
puisqu'elle vient d'être faite non pour
vous c'est beaucoup plus cool je vous
rassure tout de suite je me permettrai
pas d'imposer dès que sa femsa festive
j'ai trop de respect pour vous voilà
alors que moi quand même avant
est ce que tu es scato je t aime les
animaux
les premières sorties
merci on tombe sur adamo et belges ont
chic belge a on est retournés page ici
d'ailleurs j'en passe à l'ailé salut
voila je passe bientôt à bruxelles
très fort les belges sont offerts je
voudrais embrasser aussi les marocains
qui regardent l'émission et c'est ce que
j'étais j'ai joué là dernièrement
beaucoup de gens me regardent absolument
bien christine bonsoir donc vous publiez
un livre qui s'appelle où c'est comment
on fait christine gvt j'essaie de le
faire
voilà qui s'appelle va sur la photo la
douche non il suffit de regarder de
l'autre côté voilà la double vie de
clichy notamment d'hillary clinton
attention
[Musique]
les remarques et monsieur ménage fait ça
très bien oui mais di falco messier tout
le monde le fait ça y est c'est devenu
le truc même chez eux elle dit parents
le font chez eux le dimanche après le
repas du dimanche
incroyable alors la double vie d'hillary
clinton chez robert laffont vous dites
je ne connais pas d'histoires plus
contemporaines que celle d'hillary
clinton
c'est celle d'une femme de ma génération
qui veut tout à la fois le pouvoir le
bonheur la maternité l'indépendance la
réussite la féminité rixe un peu presque
un symbole sûrement est presque une
caricature hillary clinton
oui une caricature comme ce qui nous
paraît à nous toujours faire l'intérêt
des feuilletons américains c'est un
personnage de feuilleton réponse a
formidablement parce que non seulement
elle est le personnage central dans une
histoire qui nous a tenus en haleine
même ici pendant les années mais tous
les personnages secondaires sont à leur
tour des caricatures et je crois que
c'est la force des américains aussi on
se dit mais nous on est tellement plus
raffiné tellement plus subtile tellement
moins vulgaire plus jamais dans les
palais du pouvoir
on ferait les choses pareilles et en
fait c'est universel
est ce pour ça que ça marche et hilary
d'une certaine manière c'est vrai
qu'elle incarne
les filles de ma génération c'est vrai
qu'on a tous voulu alors vous commencez
votre livre par la victoire donc de
d'hillary clinton qui est la première
femme à être élu sénateur de l'état de
new york
et c'est vrai qu'au départ c'était pas
c'était pas gagné du tout vous raconter
d'ailleurs tout au cours du livre là la
bataille qu'elle a mené perdu parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui a attiré sur elles
tellement de haine
tellement de passion les américains en
ont tellement tu as et du feuilleton de
lui d'elle
de lui et c'est que tout le monde m'a
dit a dit elle va se planter bien
évidemment parce qu'elle aura contre
elle les femmes dit libéré c'est à dire
les féministes qui lui reprochent avec
une virulence que j'en reproduis dans
livres qui sont dans notre vie politique
anneaux qui lui reprochent évidemment de
ne pas l'avoir quittée il
et puis elle a contre elle aussi bien
évidemment les conservateurs qu'ils
disent mais comment bien sûr elle est
restée c'est normal ce n'est qu'une
fable mais en même temps ça veut dire
qu'elle est associée
oui l immoralité oui c'est ça n'a plus
de légitimité
alors vous parlez vous dit un truc
intéressant c'est que c'est en fait la
sphère monica levinsky qu'il l'a décidé
à se lancer c'est à dire qu'en fait elle
aime beaucoup bill clinton très sensible
et ce n'était pas évident pour moi avant
de lire le bouquin c'est qu'elle aime
beaucoup bill clinton moi je me
l'imaginais que c'est une relation qui
datait qui durait que c'était une espèce
d'assemblage pour l'intérêt pour le
pouvoir mais pas tellement pour l'amour
donc elle aime beaucoup clinton mais
c'est après cette affaire qu'elle décide
de se lancer elle-même dans la politique
oui parce que d'abord lui il aime
beaucoup aussi comme les couples qui
vivent ensemble longtemps et qui
assouvissent ensemble avec plus ou moins
de bonheur et quelques vicissitudes des
ambitions communes et qui ont donc une
complicité forte et un besoin de l'inde
autre constant c'est-à-dire même au pire
moment ils la paient leurs peines leurs
wagons mais au delà de ça c'est vrai que
moi ce qui m'a intéressé dans le cas de
cette femme c'est que voilà quelqu'un
qui contre toute attente elle est la
plus brillante quand elle est jeune elle
est la star du campus elle est beaucoup
plus brillantes que lui sur le plan
universitaire en tout cas et tout le
monde dit cette fille est tellement
formidable
elle sera la première femme à la cour
suprême des etats unis
là dessus elles rencontrent ces espèces
de grand escogriffe très charmant
enveloppant et c'est tombe raide dingue
amoureux lui aussi d'ailleurs
parce qu'il rencontre quelqu'un qui lui
en impose intellectuellement et qui
surtout croit ce qu'il dit et lui dit la
première fois qu'il la voit il lui dit
je serai président des états unis mais
elle commence à se dire oui d'accord
mais c'est ça le départ dès qu'elles
rencontrent les gens quand on la voit
votre livre la montre en 68 elle est
étudiante elle est meneuse et des
grosses lunettes elle et pas maquillée
enfin après il s'est fait une beauté
quoi mais au départ n est pas très sexy
intelligente prometteuse ils sont
linverse l'huile et très charmeur elle
effectivement c'est un peu une étudiante
qui se soigne pas quoi c'est ce à quoi
tout à fait ça c'est une fille très
intelligente qui comme beaucoup de
filles de cette génération féminisme
autrement virulent chez eux que chez
nous
heureusement pour vous mon nom isabelle
alonso mais ça va ah oui mais bien des
années alonso met donc c'est vrai que ce
sont des filles qui ont dit écoutez vous
nous prenez comme on est on en a marre
d'être l'objet de désir et donc on sent
les 10 et hilary au début c'est pour ça
que on a mis des photos dans livre très
très rigolo à la saison elle est
mignonne
non mais les mignonnes et après ils sont
les volontairement disons toute façon
moi je verrais nié par l'intelligence et
c'est vrai qu'elle fait le choix tout à
fait inattendue de françois dire de tout
sacrifier à l'homme qu'elle aime
en tout cas de de se réaliser à travers
lui ce qui est un choix ces antiques
oui pour une famille jusqu'à monica et
là elle se dit bon là je me marre mon
compte
alors c'est vrai que bon vous l'avez dit
les féministes la déteste pour sa
gestion de la crise conjugale
et finalement quand même à new york elle
à 60% des femmes qui votent pour elle
c'est quand même énorme
oui parce que il s'est passé deux
phénomènes qui sont très à mémé
américain mais qui en même temps reflète
bien la les rapports hommes femmes et
surtout chez eux toujours plus crispé il
ya eu un débat télévisé où son
adversaire qui est un jeune homme très
mignon qui souhaitent tout le temps bien
sous tous rapports républicain qui a
fait campagne sur le thème moi je suis
celui qui va tuer hillary envoyez moi de
l'argent donc il a récolté en argent
considérable de l'ensemble des
etats-unis
et lors du premier débat télévisé il a
fait une faute qu'aucun de nos fameuses
experts vous savez ruralistes compris
qu'ils commentent à longueur de temps un
politique n'ont pas vu il est allé
brandir sous le nez d'hillary un papier
pour l'obliger à signer un truc sur le
financement des campagnes et ça a été
perçu
par les femmes les téléspectatrices
comme une agression et dans les études
d'opinion après toutes les femmes ont
dit mais comment qu'est ce que c'est que
ces espèces de machos ce petit roquet il
ressemble à mon mari quand ils me brandi
mes relevés de banque quand j'ai trop
dépensé et ces essais étaient
logiquement alors vous pensez qu'elle
sera elle se présentera aux
présidentielles en 2004 en 2008
moi je crois mais vous pensez qu'elle a
cette ambition là ouais ok là un
l'ambition de la capacité et 3
probablement dans la mesure où encore
une fois bill ne continue pas à faire
trop de bêtises et elle non plus elle à
l'appareil du parti démocrate dont
qu'elle attendait pour devenir sinon la
première femme présidente
auquel cas je ferai un autre livre mais
en tout cas la première femme
intronisé nommé pour la wii alors vous
le rencontrez vous le rencontrez au
début des années 70 donc ça veut dire
que vous êtes quand même bien placé pour
en parler parce que c'est un moment vous
la connaissez la même coupe de cheveux
alors ah bah non leur écoute et regarde
on regarde et moi j'ai la même depuis
des années on sait qu'il arrive c'est
bien c'est elle qui nous a conviés à
changer le plus de coiffure la femme
publique dans lé christine c'est vrai
quand on lit de buka il ya un côté auto
portrait de christine okrent à londres
ouais bah oui c'est évident d'abord vous
êtes mariés tous ces deux âmes est
président mais vous vous êtes dit choix
avec kouchner vous êtes mariés ou
compagnes concubin ok ben concubin la
femme en contemporain
non ça fait un peu comme un mariage
abondamment
annoncée il ya une énorme différence
avant veut pas divorcer mérite qu'on y
réfléchisse
bah vous est toutes les deux avec un
homme politique est un séducteur parce
que coûte cher aussi séducteur moi vous
avez en commun vous les aimez
beau-parent ma vie c'est autre chose
web les mêmes stagiaires voulez vous les
aimez vous aimez shon vous aimez tous
les deux votre votre homme vous avez un
seul enfant faisait toutes les deux très
diplômés vous avez des carrières
brillantes que vous avez réalisé sans
votre des poux l'une et l'autre dans mon
cas mais pas dans tient pas quand même
c'est une avocate hillary clinton comme
une avocate
après devient la femme de bill moi jouer
cette grande erreur de vouloir faire les
choses tout seul une chanson ouais vous
et gagne de l'argent tout les deux donc
sans vos maris vous est payante
brillante ambitieuse plus tenace quand
vous avez plein plein de points communs
j'espère que c'est un compliment j'en
suis pas tout à fait sûrs avant vous et
toutes les deux des biens c'est ce qu'on
va faire maintenant
[Musique]
bien l'envié d'une famille quand même
faut le dire de la haute bourgeoisie
non mais c'est pas un reproche à et non
mais c'est pas nous c'est faux je vais
dire non aux bourgeoisies oui mérite
méritants ouais voilà votre père était
directeur de cabinet de ce pacte a été
le grand artisan belge de la
construction européenne
si vous connaissez ce pack non chez tous
été
ça c'était celle et gilles a bien failli
quand on regarde l'émission oui surgi
d'un enroulé un s'il voulait ne fume pas
pas de cabanis cabanis et déjà bon maman
oui mais pas pas comment il fait en dix
ans alors oui excusez moi testing j'ai
appris un truc vos parents ont divorcé
mais après tant d'années mais je veux
pas en parler parce que toulouse est
tout le village
un avantage assez dingue bah oui après
vingt ans ça se fête n'était pas au
courant
et oui voilà bon enfin on s'appesantit
pas là dessus parce que vous connaissez
la discrétion pour les caractères dans
cette émission on n'a toujours pas de
nom de dieu qui signale quand même et on
est presque au bout bien alors vous
arrivez à paris à l'âge de 6 ans votre
père est nommé ambassadeur c'est ça je
le collège sévigné alors là attention à
la hypo là c'est bien collège sévigné
ensuite fait sciences po est alors
imaginer que si nos craintes à sciences
po petit tailleur en tweed petit
shetland à moi je vois très bien petit
shetland petite mini cooper blanc
absolument avec un filet noir un filet
noir de suie voilà sièges noirs
équitation mademoiselle aux craintes à
l'époque que préfère brel aux beatles
quand même elle lit les bouddhistes
aussi brel ouais tout le monde c'est
quand même moi l'époque je préférais
comme les beatles
vous lisez les mémoires d'hadrien de
marguerite yourcenar seulement
excellence vous visez parents à tous les
jeunes gens pas de nouveau roman pas
trop payés jamais trop compris voilà
et vous avez le culot de dire ça c'est
énorme je n'étais pas conformiste à
sanaa ce que cech roger meece a dit ça
après tout à des sculptures des deux
petits shetland et de la mini cooper ou
dit je n'étais pas confiant à dire c'est
peut-être juste une apparence aussi
[Rires]
vous n'étiez pas conformiste comme on
vient de le voir vous sortez major de
sciences po quand même pas mal en fin de
votre section vous allez à cambridge
quand même il a évidemment vous trouver
un petit job bce mais ça c'est par
piston un an j'ai fait pour mon
troisième cycle de sciences politiques
il a fait l'ena mais n'est pas bon mais
c'est bon ça contrevient à des
informations
c'est vrai ce que je dis non il était
quand même top bcbg donc là vous rentrez
chez nbc faut dire vous avez commencé
quand même au bas de l'échelle vous
étiez brouillon on peut dire un
sallanches éolien bouillotte brouillonne
c'est que christine aller à orly à
dédouaner les cassettes aller à l'époque
à l'époque fit donc voilà pour une robin
dans des boîtes en fer comprenez dans
les salles voilà l aléa on lira pendant
vous avez dit d'ailleurs pendant que les
autres quitter les classes moi je
faisais mes classes et puis après de fil
en aiguille quand même parce que cette
ambitieuse c'est pas un proche de basse
à vous bossez vous devenez réalisatrice
journalistes et vous partez aux usa chez
sybille s et là vous participé pendant
six ans 1,6 team elite ce qu'est le
grand magazine d'information américains
voyaient ce jeu me combien de temps
entre entre orly 6 10 minutes j'ai fait
ça un an et demi rien au rugby c'est
bien ensuite bon vous passer six ans là
bas si vous commencez à renouer avec la
france à travers un magazine qui
s'appelait vendredi sur france 3 vous
amorcez votre retour en france
alors après 80 vous arrivez au journal
télévisé de france 2 enfin d'antenne 2 à
l'époque en alternance avec ppda et
après tout seul quand ppda est parti
boucher rester jusqu'à 85 et alors là je
vois comment vous êtes arrivé à ce
journal vous êtes je vous reproche pas
mais vous êtes vraiment ambitieuse 1 les
mecs alors eux ils sont là ils placent
prendre tous les samedis il faut une
audience maximale
il veut faire le 28 sept en titre n'ont
pas tout de suite faire le vanuatu 10 et
15 heures
car 0 peut-être moins pas tout de suite
voilà l an après dès qu'ils voient femme
qu'il faut faire c'est l'été 80 des
groupes est en vacances antibes vous
chercher son numéro dans l'annuaire
vous le trouvez vous l'appelez au flanc
vite voilà je veux présenter le 21 pas
du tout à quoi bon vouloir plus drôle
c'est face à lisieux là j'appelle des
groupes
j'ai une grande admiration pour des
groupes 5 colonnes etc j'en avais marre
de me lever à 3h15 du matin pour faire
du journal de 8h sur hot c'est vraiment
très message combine bref
j'appelle des gros que juni voilà
monsieur cetera il me dit ah c'est vous
il me dit j'aime pas votre voix donc
c'était déjà un bon début
et puis m'a donné rendez vous à paris et
alors bourgon vous est peut-être venue
des groupes qui était un merveilleux
vieux monsieur qui avait un très très
mauvais caractère ce qui fait qu'il a
été à chaque fois vidés par les hommes
politiques pardon qui ne supportait pas
son indépendance d'esprit celui est
arrivé plusieurs fois dans la vie et
donc il me reçoit il vient d'être nommé
président d'antenne 2 alors il a 7 clope
au bec qui me regarde je ne pense pas qu
est ce que je pourrais bien lui faire
faire et moi je pensais franchement pas
au 20 heures
moi j'arrivais en gros du grand
reportage et j'avais jamais d'accord ce
que vous dites que j'en sais pas au 20
heures
mais on n'est pas du tout du tout bon
mon truc moi je voulais faire un
magazine faut faire du reportage c'était
vous avez offert par exemple est dit un
bel 20 heures tu vois le vote
et là c'est énorme parce que vous étiez
la première femme à présenter le 20h
je vais ramasser je commence alors qu'il
faisait le ramassage pas combien de sept
d'or d'honneur là c'était la reine
christine cette époque de l'année
christine c'est qu'en france on coupe
les têtes
ah ben oui je suis bien placé pour
savoir pauvre marie antoinette qui nous
regardent je suis moi sens
vous avez touché juste donc là vous
partez à tf1 pour 240 mille francs par
mois
oui ce qu'était par rapport à d'autres
d'affairé paraissent contrairement et
vous en serez rapidement au conflit et
patrick le lay quand ils auront comme
sia kambou moulant jusque là rien
d'étonnant en 88
vous revenez sur france 2 et la scandale
parce que vous baissez votre salaire de
moitié ses 240 passer à 120 alors même
mois il ya une cabale qu'est lancé par
paul amar et qui dit moi je pense à moi
de congé si elle gagne 120 mille balles
par mois je pense à moi de congé est
donc une grève certains étaient
relativement soulagés à l'idée qu'il
s'en aille c'est vrai bien et là dans là
je rigole pas parce que vous avez
vraiment souffert je pense sérieusement
vous rentrez dans un restaurant les gens
disaient avec quoi elle a payé son
manteau avec l'argent des contribuables
vous aviez l'impression d'être tondus en
44 non c'était assez pénible
ouais c'était assez pénible de l'orge
est malade les pneumonies perfusion
assistance respiratoire
il ya même un journal qui écrit à
l'époque c'est pas vrai elle n'est pas
l'hôpital tout ça c'est bidon savez à
quel point les journalistes peuvent être
méchants
non mais c'est pas honnêtement vous avez
j'imagine un débat vela ouais mais moi
je vais vous dire un truc le plus
choquant pour moi dans toute cette
affaire s'est passé rien de tout ça
jusqu'au veille d'hab on vous est
expliqué antenne de l'histoire du
salaire les gens gagnent tellement plus
aujourd'hui
moi ce que je trouve de plus choquant
dans toute votre carrière
si le 12 avril 92 vous interviewez
françois mitterrand avec anne sinclair
et là on voit une chose absolument
extraordinaire que j'aurais jamais pensé
voir de ma vie c'est à dire un président
de la république est interviewé par deux
femmes de ministres
ça c'est en partie exact nous faisions
partie d'un groupe de six journalistes
qui avaient été choisies comme
d'habitude à l'époque par le regretté
jacques billand oui il y avait des
représentants de chaque chaîne
il y avait entre autres un ancien mari
d'anne sinclair
oui j'ai des amis là on était cette voie
là et personne comme je crois qu'on s'y
bierne que moi avions quelques qualités
qualités professionnelles de la pensée
il a fallu un académicien par ailleurs
tout à fait charmant un effort
admirateur des compliments c'est à dire
que je sois monde derrière il va morfler
qu'est ce qu'il a dit dans le sens et ya
fait un papier en disant mais comment
aller président qui fait intervenir
il a un peu heureusement d'étape est
tombé dans les vous l'aurez christine
ockrent seulement vous ne mangez pas
pour ses seconds pour plein de raisons
mais talbot moi j'ai toujours fait mon
parcours professionnel
seul oui j'ai eu l'immense bonheur de
rencontrer bernard assez tard dans ma
vie le tard à mon goût mais donc
beaucoup plus tard et il était vraiment
absurde on la sort la police et médecins
sans frontières médecins du monde donc
voilà honnêtement avouer que ça fait
bizarre
vous êtes devant votre télé voyez
présent à public interview par deux
femmes de ministres mais vous avez pas
l'étiquette fin 2006 vous êtes vous êtes
quelqu'un en l'occurence moi qui a
présenté des centaines de journaux
télévisés sur est-ce qu'on peut être
aussi impertinents avec un présent à
public quant aux nations unies elles
étaient sinon impertinente en tout cas
suffisamment précises dans quelques
questions à l'époque je me souviens sur
quelques amitiés qu'il pouvait avoir
pour que le président très sèchement
n'ai plus envie de me parler
donc on prend pire d'ailleurs fort bien
alors
d'ailleurs bernard kouchner vous êtes
d'accord avec ça bernard kouchner par
une odeur bernard kouchner a signé en
l'appel du 18 juin pour légaliser la
marijuana maintenant qu'il est au
ministère de la santé vous croyez qu'il
va aider mais il a déjà fait beaucoup il
a mis en place sous il a fait nommer
madame maestracci
il essaie de faire évoluer les
mentalités
sur un sujet qui en france par
comparaison avec ce qui se passe dans
d'autres volets duc de crispation et
d'hypocrites et la mentalité qu'il faut
faire évoluer ses les gouvernants parce
que les mentalités sont des mentalités
français les mentalités des gouverneurs
non d'accord et ce qu'ils croient être
les réactions de leurs électeurs qu'on
est dans un no tunes chantier j'aime pas
encore dans vos émissions vous poser la
question sur le cabanis bien alors
attention
maintenant on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Musique]
et si vous préférez draguer ou faire
draguer tu préfères draguer préféré
embrasser ou faire embrasser
ça dépend qui scelle la joie coin
préféré caresser ou faire caresser les
concepts question je suis désolé son oui
je ne vais pas le dire
voilà l homme va pas sans l'autre
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
n'importe bonne réponse de que sinon
qu'elle est le lieu où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour en revanche
dans un ascenseur a pour quelques
immeubles sont passés au en france je
vous ai besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pourrait
mais j'ai besoin des billets souvent les
filles la différence entre les filles et
les gars font ça est ce que vous
préférez ah oui un mec qui bosse bien
mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse
mâles mais qui est fidèle à faire ne pas
à essayer enfin fier c'est compliqué
comme question qu'on se permette
c'est pas les bras
il préférait attendre dessus ces
interviews belge préféré un mec il fait
moins que l'on peut voler c'est un
michel et sa mère
oui c'est le show mais une fois on peut
aussi parler comme ça vous est si serré
mais plutôt de bruxelles ah oui moi
j'adore ah je croyais qu'avec vous suis
ravi ça fait ma soirée en forme en faut
peu finalement
ah oui dans le coup vous vous pensez
qu'il faut pas savoir où tout se dire je
vois qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut se
dire des choses qu'il ne faut pas encore
très bien
est-ce que vous avez des fantasmes non
encore réalisés bien sûr d'abord et vous
un jour dirai pas lesquels je vous
demande dans lesquelles nous allons
j'essaye de précéder vous voulez vous
voulez réaliser vous avez dans l'idée de
vous et vous acharnez avait réalisé des
idées aux obsèques d'un encore des trucs
à faire quoi c'est à l'âme c'est à dire
plein voilà merci
si le trad du lard et qu'une
chez robert laffont
[Musique]
non mesdames messieurs j'accueille
bateau
[Musique]
michel desjoyeaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un très long moment où
et en france un bon desjoyeaux est oui
oui
et oui sables d'olonne sables d'olonne
vingt-cinq mille milles 3 mois et demi
en mer en solitaire année 2 au serbe
[Musique]
et ça m
campo
oui rex bactéries
[Musique]
twins plus haut
elle est pour
actu
où
[Musique]
vous
ce sens
[Applaudissements]
c'est le pensons
[Musique]
soir
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
borloo bravo alors vous appelle mich dej
où le professeur parce que c'est vrai
que vous êtes un génie de l'innovation
va voir vous avez inventé des trucs pour
les bateaux vous êtes breton né à
concarneau
alors jusque là on vous avez connu comme
un des plus grands figaristes de ces dix
dernières années
et puis là avec le quatrième vendée
globe vous avez fait votre premier tour
du monde en solitaire en plus c'est la
première fois que vous le faisiez c'est
pas et des gens que l'on ne gagne qu ils
ont déjà réussi la première fois il ya
un début à tout il ya un début à tout
non c'est vrai que déjà lors de votre
naissance votre mère pour aller à
l'hôpital maternité pour accoucher il y
avait des embouteillages et donc un
moment des faits y aller en voiture
amphibie et puis finalement bon ça c'est
réglé végétales et par la route mais
déjà il y avait quand même une
prédestination
votre père était dans le ski mais quand
dans la résistance il a connu vianney et
vianney qu'il embarquait dans les
bateaux et et votre père a été un des
fondateurs de l'école des glénans
donc effectivement tout ça ça vous
prédispose est fortement à ce que vous
avez fait vous avez grandi au milieu de
son garage à bateaux parce que votre
père était le premier à faire un garage
pour les bateaux de plaisance je me
souviens plus très bien si parce que
vous étiez tout petit vous avez été
élevé dans les copeaux et dans l'est
dans les bars et de coaltar parce que il
y avait des ouvriers donc quand il avait
besoin dans ce dans ce chantier naval
ils avaient besoin d'un petit pour elle
à la pointe du bateau bah on a appelé un
petit desjoyeaux quoi ça pouvait être
voué petit gabarit le moose quel était
le dernier donc gérer alors votre maire
faisait là faisait l'école très tard
votre mère vous faisait la classe dans
la salle dans la salle à manger et votre
cour de récré c'était le chantier naval
donc de là était vraiment élevé là
dedans
et quand vous étiez en classe soutien au
fond de la classe début de l'année
j'étais au fond de la classe et petit à
petit avant ferait ce qu'elle prend
voulait me voir d'un peu plus près pour
y signer des grès brand et coop d'emad
ont vraiment été levées là dedans
service militaire vous apprenez la météo
l'informatique d'en profiter et à 18 ans
vous embarquez sur le pen duick 6-2
tabarly et en 92 première victoire donc
dans le solitaire du figaro entre temps
mini transat et vous innovez ce que je
disais tout à l'heure vous inventez la
quille pendulaire pas la kia bascule
quoi c'est pas vous j'ai pas la
prétention d'avoir
d'avoir inventé parce que j'aime hôtels
ça existait déjà mais par contre je les
remises au goût du jour et en grains une
étape de la mini a pris de l'ampleur et
maintenant c'est devenu une ne riez pas
réussi la télé vous êtes trop modeste
moi je veux m'en aller
alors là vous avez réussi dans le bateau
qui va bien et c'est vraiment modeste
moi j'ai lu des déclarations vous avez
fait après votre victoire
c'est vraiment aux sables-d'olonne c'est
vraiment vous êtes très très modeste
alors vendée globe
cinq cent mille francs de notes de
téléphone deux fois plus non si c'est
votre femme qui vous prend la terre faut
l'appeler toute la journée je crois pas
non non deux fois plus bon c'est de la
minute
il ya eu des écoutes il paraît qu est-ce
qui disait grosso modo dans le million
de francs qui va être dépensé en
communication il ya le million il ya à
peu près on va dire moitié technique et
moitié soutien moral
oui c'est vrai il faut le reconnaître on
va sur internet à 8 dollars 45 minutes
quand on a fait de la transmission
d'image moi j'en ai peu fait j'en ai
fait que sur la première moitié
ça m'est arrivé je devrais pas le dire
parce que mon sponsor rames bondées mais
de m'endormir pendant la transmission et
je me suis réveillée au bout de deux
heures et la machine continue donc vous
faites le calcul ça c'est qui votre
sponsor dit le nom parce que comme il a
payé vous avez gagné autant de dire non
ben prb produits dont lentement du
bâtiment info liette compagna vers
l'algérie sondernach vous appelez votre
femme trois fois par jour puisque ce que
ça veut dire c'est que même quand on
fait le tour du monde en solitaire
on a quand même sa femme trois fois par
jour au téléphone donc y'a pas moyen
y'a pas moyen de leur échapper aux
jalousies ça va
vous aviez emporté un bouquin qui est
d'une vous avez oublié le troisième tome
ça d'être énorme ça j'imagine quand on a
fini 2e peu mais pour immerger oublier
le troisième tome et qu'on est obligé de
la mer c'est un de mes préparateurs qui
avait mis ça dans une dans une enveloppe
étanche dans l'avant du bateau il a
fallu que je fasse une des visites
d'inspection de la structure du bateau
parce que c'était dans un des caissons
étanches qui à l'avant pour découvrir
une enveloppe qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
oublié cet endroit là on laisse pas
traîner des trucs et allart dedans il y
avait le que le tome 1 et j'attends avec
impatience de là et avoir le temps
d'aller en vacances là bas ça fait 35
ans que je suis en vacances
ouais c'est sympa de dire ça alors
évidemment vous ne vous étonnerez pas
que je vous pose cette question le sexe
non vous la mettez sous le bras
ouais c'est ça c'est ça notre arrivée
nan mais ce qu'il a déclaré quand il est
arrivé aux gars dit y at il quelque
chose de plus bouquins câlins avec vos
enfants à l'arrivée du vendée globe et
vous avez répondu oui à un truc plus
beau c'est un câlin avec leur mère c'est
un peu comme bruno solo qui nous a
raconté après sa campagne de promo pour
la vérité si je mens il avait hâte de
rentrer en belgique aussi pendant la
période de la promo il n'était pas sur
un bateau tout ça là là c'est un honneur
vous allez vous marier
non mais c'est marrant ça alors mais
pourquoi voulez vous je sais pas et avec
elle depuis longtemps ça se passe bien
commun raison de plus pour pas avoir
besoin
voilà comme christine et vous le mariage
c'est un truc culturel nous dit oui
c'est quitte avec ses longues et âmes à
merde les tenants de la religion
judéo-chrétienne je ne me marierai pas
un mais vous voilà au jour le jour c'est
excitant ou marisa pas avec eux bon
alors voilà vous avez retour d'indiens
et on a enfin maintenant donc je me mets
à votre place parce que sinon le pire
titeuf c'est pas ça c'est trois mois
enfin je crois qu'on vous habitez en 93
jours un mois et trois mois trois mois
et puis vous arrivez ici été fait ouais
quand même
oui agoria par rapport aux précédents
vainqueurs heureusement qu une brisure
l'addition merci que si la crème dites
moi non mais ça veut dire c'est la
première fois qu'on fait le tour du
monde en moins de cent jours donc non
seulement en solitaire donc non
seulement en michel mais aussi
téléphone ellen macarthur ouais après
que les gens tel un vautour en mana
j'accélère je sais moi il ya une chose
qui m'a beaucoup ému quand il est arrivé
c'est qu'il a dit ok on ne salue mois
mais pensez à ceux qui sont encore en
cours il y en a encore ah oui le dernier
c'est un avocat c'est un avocat italien
qu'à 60 ans et qui est en train de faire
son tour du monde mais il le fait au
milieu dans le court c'est quoi votre
prochain voyage comme ça dans votre
prochaine course
non je sais pas avant
[Musique]
mais
alors michel desjoyeaux comme vous avez
pris beaucoup de vagues de vie des hauts
et des bas on va vous faire une
interview à penda c'est normal on est à
gauche
[Musique]
quel a été le meilleur moment de la
course la bonne option à l'entrée dans
les mers du sud où je prends la tête
presque définitive alors le pire moment
la gueule de bois du pr la gueule de
bois du 1er janvier
ah bon pas pour le taux d'alcool dans le
sang mais pour un problème de démarreur
je me suis dit là la fête est finie
vous étiez où là on venait heureusement
on venait de passer la nouvelle zélande
donc il me restait tout pacifique devant
moi dix jours délai souhaité passer le
réveillon fait comme sol comme ça ça
doit être écoutée j'avais j'avais à
borges avait tout ce qu'il fallait
j'avais les sarbacanes les langues de
belle-mère je vais me cacher derrière la
base j'avais des bonnes bouteilles et
puis j'ai pas pu non plus oublier le
lendemain michel ruiz itron j'étais tout
seul et sous mes pieds n'y avait rien
peut-être à dakar et vous parlez du
bateau comme d'un comme da comme on peut
parler d'un cheval finalement non mais
c'est vrai si j'en rêve
les gens ils parlent du cheval disons
souvent oui ouais bah ça doit être ça
doit être ça ce que vous préférez dans
le bateau avant le fait de faire du
bateau la grande la liberté ça vous
détestez les contraintes qu'elle
contraint les contraintes qu'on a à
terre mais pas de tissi ce soir avec
vous je vous rassure ça va
les contraintes de
d'avoir toujours envie d'en faire plus
c'est d'être d'être tenus par des choses
qui nous empêchent d'être totalement
libre avec un bon moteur ah mais ça
existe aussi il ya le tour du monde en
moteurs un moteur ils ont fait iphone ça
aussi ce que vous préférez en gros je
vais être prétentieux mais c'est ce que
vous avez une fois vous êtes tellement
modeste en général a justement la
modestie
profitez-en avoue préférer la modestie
c'est bien ce que vous détestez en vous
mon sale caractère mais personne ne te
connais comme je le connais ça se voit
pas du tout changement débrouille tout
seul est ce que vous trouvez de mieux
dans la vie d'avoir de ce que je disais
tout à l'heure ça fait 35 ans que je
suis en vacances c'est sa main ça veut
pas dire que je ne fais rien celle que
je fais ce que j'aime avec mon bébé mon
métier c'est d'abord une passion ça
c'est ce qu'à mieux mais ce qui est pire
dans la vie pour vous c'est quoi le jour
où ça s'arrêtera way votre plus gros
coup de fric je viens de réaliser il ya
quelques ya dix jours avant pour dire
plus oh ben ça va être ça va pas une
plongée la note de téléphone parce que
c'est pas sur le même budget mais elle
ne sent pas de valeur n'a rien dit dans
les votes plus grosses pertes
financières
zéro abonde fait pas passer en négatif
c'est bien alors je n'ai pas le souvenir
alors brice vous gérez bien votre
business ce que vous avez de plus sexy
en vous ça c'est mes voisines de l'irb
elles peuvent le dire
marie les yeux des yeux et c'est le nez
le nez christine c'est que la vie n'est
pas pour rien dans ce que vous avez de
moins sexy en vous je ne sais pas les
maps par exemple ça monte hellman comme
ça ces cinq là pour une femme le contact
des masses et panoz comme ça ça a été
beaucoup plus ce qui est bien pire ça
vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous en
solitaire beaucoup la balle attention ce
que vous préférez dans le sexe l'amour
ce que vous détestez dans le sexe
l'ennui
[Musique]
et maintenant
maintenant nous arrivons climax de cette
émission mesdames messieurs c'est le
blind test
[Musique]
un blind test ce soir en hommage à
charles trenet donc nous entendrons des
reprises de chansons de charles trenet
par d'autres interprètes mais est ce que
je vous demanderai à vous tous ici c'est
de me donner les interprètes bien
entendu parce que les titres des
chansons les connaît mais d'abord pour
animer et arbitrer ce blind test mans /
filippo coup
la fin de ce mois et du soleil dans les
moeurs
la joie
vous ne finirez français bonjour bonjour
des deux modèles madonna vient alors en
finir comment ça va se passer
dommage parce que j'ai vu qu'il avait un
super coullier policière ah ben oui
quand il est arrivé
donc est ce qu'on peut en mettre un à
tout le monde ah oui même à nous et on a
joué ce soir donc puisque c'est charles
trenet oui le soleil qui avait rendez
vous avec la ligue d'accord ça te plait
ça tire et ça me plaît beaucoup la
jusqu'ici tout va bien je trouve tes
amis formant alors gina qui est une
jeune chanteuse s'est invitée aux médias
qu'il a bien voilà et voilà voilà
ou bien alors attention on était ici
c'est le soleil est au rendez vous avec
la lune a rendez vous avec très bien
philips est parfait jusqu'ici on
commence didier premières chansons
e
[Musique]
jamais
oui c'est compliqué vous avez dit que
vous avez dit eddy mitchell et vous avez
dit claude françois et vous avez tous
raison parce qu'effectivement c'est eddy
mitchell et que françois donc un partout
donc un partout progressé de un point
ici un bruit si la louve deuxième
chanson didier sur le toit de l'hôtel
les gens lisaient les toits dont
j'attends
chanter plus fort
richard qui chante mes chats sur les
toits avec m
je sais que je
et voici
si les poneys
[Musique]
on se casse olalala amener un peu gêné
mais si vous appelez comment première
fois à 3 c ce soir c'est parce qu'on a
triplé
attention attention attention marie
gilles a régné tout serge est ce qu'on
peut faire un petit ripper s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
on est resté
désolé ça nous aura permis de le
connaître en même temps barrot le
contrôle vidéo hd et bravo donc ça fait
en année ou sur les points là deux
impliquent la m2a elle est l'une mène
par 2 points parce qu'on se sent que les
voix voilà très bien bien
alors didier chanson 03 machina nom le
nom des six jours biabiany par l'égalité
barrett a une vraie culture à cultiver à
des prix bien en continu une quatrième
[Musique]
rien
et
si vous
non
très bien je manque les eaux après bien
bien bien sans son numéro 5
il a tout ça
les prix
il est amer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
à vérifier
non maintenant c'est pas dans le comté
juste pour voir comme ça ces enjeux les
deux camps mais maintenant c'est passé
très compliqué je vous envoie juste les
écouter didier houi 4000 version de la
mère
[Musique]
les prix n'ont hélas le prénom est
français incroyable mais vrai bravo vous
connaissez ça vous c'est incroyable vous
appelez comment la bravoure et demi vous
êtes une star et rayonner dans 26 villes
et l'a6 jordi plusieurs contacts directs
la six
[Musique]
m
il ya les jeux
et il
sacha distel
c'était plusieurs mois ils ont plusieurs
sens
c'est intéressant
kirin au bayern la chanson du cinéma
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes fort dès qu'on parle de cinéma
assez fou les regards dont on connaît
les charlots elle pour l'instant ils
gagnent à las vegas et nina quand ils
sont là trois pour les soleils et 4 pour
les lunes essentielle mais recettes
didier très compliqué
le travail
très compliqué c'est un brésilien estime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gilbert toro bravo c'est très peu connu
pourquoi j'ai l'air
bien que moi quelle musique tu veux que
j'écoute
c'est vrai on lui fait un compliment et
pourquoi j'ai l'air non non non non
c'est là bien c'est génial
jean bertho bravo alors maintenant
chanson numéro huit du viè quand j'en
reviens pas et georges mas après l'âge
que vous allez prendre connaissez savoir
si votre pape a écouté son nom son
fiancé qui est là cette fois très bien
la lune comme ça didier je voudrais
qu'on passe à la chanson numéro 10
[Musique]
mon temps mais pour
le québécois est belle jeune fille
bouvier ça c'est son fiancé lorsqu'on va
maintenant c'est encore là si vous
trouvez ça vous êtes fort didier mais
moi la petite chanson là qui vient dans
le dit cela
[Musique]
c'est miharu cauchy la fonction
m'aperçois vous connaissez vraiment je
crois qu'avec béatrice qui connaît sa
wii pour l'instant à égalité à l'entamé
ou égalité parfaite en salle on va
arriver au super banco alors attention
super banco didier de france d'europe
très dur ses rivaux ferme
ceux qui comme les indiens et
on va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai ressenti sur moi je fais tu fais
pareil en effet pour 96 chalets en bois
très dur
[Musique]
non
pourtant l'élu me retrouver quand même
tout et sofia les luttes de tous nous
retrouver en internationaux par le titre
du groupe i à l'une d'elles a jamais
rien d'anti duroux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très dur mais franchement c'est
très dur ce sont les tueurs de la lune
de miel qu'il avait dit avait alors t'as
pas vu bien vient camarades à manado
l'a7
non mais tu l'avais dit vraiment oui
c'est bien comment tu les connais pas et
si les bons chanteurs voiture beaucoup
de bras merci merci beaucoup merci à
tous
c'était donc une égalité parfaite voilà
c'était tout le monde en parle
l'embellie sexe magouille et culture
générale
une pièce de laurent baffie avec
l'embellie pascal sellem mado maurin
dans par ci et j'ai envie de donner
guerra au théâtre du gymnase
luis fernandez entraîneur de l'équipe
est plus prêt du psg
mathilde seigner à la fiche du film de
claude miller la chambre des magiciennes
le 28 février avec un brochet ali noël
yves jacques faudel sortie de l'album de
claudel sèmera quitteront promo lilas à
l'olympia le 11 mai marie gillain à la
fiche du film de bruno chiche
barnie et ses petites contrariétés avec
nathalie baye fabrice luchini et hugo
spire gilles
âge du pouvoir passe au terrorisme
moyen-orientale 1981-1986 aux éditions
fayard pitof en tournée à partir du 1er
mars
christine au crack la double vide
hillary clinton si robert laffont michel
desjoyeaux qui a remporté le vendée
globe en avant mais nous avons encore à
la barre du prb et jean rappelle la
sortie du film de jean michel bernard je
te qu'on le 28 février avec anthony
delon
frédéric diefenthal jean michel bernard
et patrick chesnais voilà c'était tout
bon lanta l'émission pas comme les
autres
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
m
no
[Musique]
m
une
[Musique]
c'est
mais
[Applaudissements]
on a
on
non
[Musique]
tél
non
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
oh non
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
oh
m
non
là